Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Hey Fella.
Hey,
what's going on?
Not much.
How are you?
I'm good.
I'm great.
Wonderful.
We're a little fucking high ride.
We're going to get through it.
I'm so bummed.
I was thinking about going to Hawaii the
other day and then his volcano happened.
I'm like,
of all the times I was there,
I.
Oh,
you were there when it happened.
It was in Lanai.
I was on one of the other islands.
Did you feel the earthquake?
No,
I didn't feel it.
It's,
you know,
it's separated by quite a lot is a lot
of water and the way the big earthquake
happened actually after the plane took
off,
so we were in the air when the big one
hit.
Yeah.
Which it's apparently a big one,
like a five nine.
I think it was even more than that.
Was it six?
Oh,
oh,
right.
They had a big one and then they had a
fucking really big one in five night's
big.
I think the way it works,
I'm sure someone will correct me here.
I think the way it works is a five.
Six is like really powerful,
but a five,
seven is twice as powerful than a five.
Eight is twice as powerful as that.
So when you get up to seven,
like that's some world changing shit.
It's actually six point nine.
Oh my God.
That's insane.
Can you imagine being on the icon?
Was that powerful?
That's so big.
That's such a big earthquake,
man.
Did you see the um,
I put it up.
It's so funny,
Dude.
You put up anything that's from CNN and
people want you to put it up from a
verifiable source.
Not Cnn.
CNN is bullshit.
It's a video.
You fucking asshole.
It's a video of lava eating a car.
My stake.
CNN faked.
It was great to say I'll look to see
conclusive evidence that CNN is not full
of shit.
And then I'll go to their website.
Stupid to people are so goofy,
so goofy with this fake new shit.
It's lava.
It ate a car.
It happened.
Did you see the video?
Yeah,
the white,
the white car.
Polish it up.
I think it's good that that cards
forever going to be in rock.
So like when we all died in like the
future,
like people can like find this car,
the,
it's broken down to the bare elements at
this point,
I'm assuming it just got completely
melted.
I wonder.
They say that stuff is 2000 degrees and
it's so hot,
but it's molten rock.
So like if it didn't burn through your
feet or if you,
if you weren't flammable at all for some
strange reason,
you could actually walk on it.
I'm like,
what?
I cut thought you would just sink in it,
but no,
it apparently it's cooling like right
out of after it gets out of the surface.
Oh this is so crazy.
This is like a monster.
So we're watching this lava flow on
Hawaii's big island.
I liked how Jamie went with CBS news,
bro folk the food news.
Actually Brandon Clement got the video.
Oh powerful.
Brendan Clement.
But this guy,
whoever he is a bad motherfucker because
look what he was next to.
He was filming this.
I mean he was near this thing.
Oh my God.
Like imagine being on that street and
staying.
What kind of a crazy fuck you have to be
to be on that street and stay and then
it's six point nine hits during all
this.
That's so big.
That's such a crazy earthquake,
but they live on a volcano.
I mean,
it's one of the reasons why a lot of
people don't want to live on the big
island.
So shit like this.
Yeah,
that's splatter.
One's crazy that there's a fissure in
this neighborhood.
There's a subdivision out there and
something estates.
I forget what it is,
but they're fucking April.
Do the.
The,
the ground opened up in their
neighborhood.
I mean,
if you lived,
you know,
thousands of years ago,
this would be an angry God coming to
attack your village.
Could you imagine if normal days you're
in Hawaii,
you're in one of the most beautiful
places on the planet.
You're just chilling and the sun is
perfect and you'd seen the ocean,
you hear the seagulls and you see
dolphins and shit,
and then the ground opens up and hell
starts pouring out.
Eats your house each Mustang fuck.
And they were talking about it today in
the news.
They're like,
there's nothing we can do.
There's nothing that I can pour water
on.
Nope,
can't do shit.
You're not going to stop it.
It's too big.
They apparently stopped it from doing
something in like Iceland and they had
to use billions and billions of gallons
of water to halt the progress of the
lava.
I forget what it was.
That big plume was in the air and you
couldn't fly anywhere.
I believe so.
And that is also that plume being in the
air,
which restricted flying is all tied into
the death of that journalist.
Michael Hastings.
Do you know that?
Oh,
that crazy conspiracy theory.
It's one of the weirder ones,
man.
It's one of the weirder ones.
This guy,
Michael Hastings was this sort of
renegade journalist type character and
he went to Iraq or Afghanistan,
um,
I want to say Iraq,
but it might've been Afghanistan.
He went there with the troops and he got
stuck there because of that volcano.
So because you stuck there,
everybody got comfortable with him being
around.
They started saying crazy shit to start
joking around about Obama and stuff like
that.
And he put all this in the article and
when you put all this in the article,
that general had to resign and he was
like one of the most popular and most
powerful generals in the army.
Then shortly thereafter,
homeboy decided to go 120 miles an hour
down sunset and slammed into a tree and
his car exploded and everybody's like,
it's a fucking burger.
Hits assassination.
And then there was all these tech guys
that were coming out and they were
saying,
listen,
you absolutely can hack a car and change
the direction.
Change the,
the what,
what the car does take control of the
car.
You absolutely can do.
And they were like,
abs.
Absolutely.
He was like,
absolutely you can absolutely.
One hundred percent.
You do it.
Do you have.
We know these people,
there's videos of people falling asleep
in their Teslas,
right?
The car just drives you there.
You get on the highway,
just drives you.
We know that's real.
It turns,
it'll turn,
will make turns for you.
It'll park.
They have cars,
the park.
You don't think that they can,
that they figured out a long time ago
say,
wouldn't it be cool if we could just tap
into that and make this motherfucker
drive into a tree or star kids?
They didn't.
They would be so incompetent that I
don't want to hear any conspiracy
theories ever again because of the
government didn't look at that stuff.
If the government like this assassins
didn't look at that angle.
Bobo Bobo.
Hold on a second.
So you telling me if the head of Isis is
in a car and it's a Mercedes,
we can hack into that car and make that
motherfucker drive off a cliff.
We can do that.
Okay,
well let's do that
100 percent.
Those people all day of trying to figure
out a way to kill bad guys.
You don't think they would think that?
Of course they would.
So that's the scary thought.
But then the other possibility is
homeboy was losing his mind because of
the pressure,
which is entirely possible.
You always have to like look at
everything.
You've got to look at all sides.
You really do.
It's so.
It's so easy to just pick a side on any
story or a conspiracy theory or
anything,
even a political opinion,
so easy to just dig your heels in,
but in this one you gotta look at this
guy.
They definitely found amphetamines in
his system.
They said,
and that's not uncommon for writers.
Writers love adderall.
It fucking love it.
Apparently.
I have a friend who's a journalist,
says everybody who's a journalist is on
adderall.
Obviously.
He's exaggerating the one guy's out
there,
like,
no folk,
not fucking mood,
but um,
who was it that was a doctor?
Oh,
my friend,
Dr Roddy Mckee the,
the stem cell doctor from Vegas.
He was telling me about people that were
taken adderall like when he was in
college and he's like,
Holy Shit,
it's my breasts mail
throws me listerine strips.
Okay Dude,
I'll fucking take one.
Blindly flipped it.
But he was saying that Williamson
colleges like a market change in
everybody's performance.
Once they started doing the adderall.
I believe it.
Jamie gave it to me.
He gave me a little tiny piece,
allegedly.
Maybe not.
Maybe I just made that up officer.
I don't know what that was.
I don't know what the fuck that was.
I didn't take it either way.
I'm,
I'm scared of it.
I'm scared.
I'm gonna take it and go.
Yes.
This is what I need.
Right.
Like the same,
same reason.
I would be scared of coke.
I've never fucked with coke.
I like coffee too much.
I like it.
I drink it,
but I'm not even tired.
I'll just look for a cup of coffee,
like come on in,
have a cup of coffee and be nice.
Right now I feel like I crack like
cracky when I'm on adderall lake as it
could get into like the whole time to
make you talk too much.
Uh,
I've only done like three times,
but I remember I tried to do it and go
on stage and it was awful.
I felt like I was on.
My timing was all like jeter,
Gdg,
gender,
gender.
When you got to take into account like
there's the way you feel before you go
onstage and it there's the way you feel
onstage,
the adrenaline you have to take into
account that that adrenaline is going to
be there.
It's kind of mix in.
Yeah.
I did modafinil once.
It did modafinil on stage and it was a
weird little balancing act.
That's that pro vigil stuff,
right?
It was weird.
It was like,
Whoa,
this is weird.
You know,
you better off sober.
You just put the.
The thing about those pills apparently
is he get used to it and then you get
used to that juice.
You know,
you're used to just fucking have the
energy to get shit done.
Come on Brian.
Let's start a fucking business.
Let's organize.
We've got to make a nonprofit that
carries the same name as
everybody gets super,
super fired up,
but you can get a lot of shit done that
way.
So that's the thing with journalists
apparently according to my friend,
he's like,
dude,
everybody's on it.
They're all on it and they write like
maniacs.
They just fucking pound the keys.
But it makes sense in that take your
pills documentary on Netflix.
That's what they talk about too.
I need to see that percent of kids in
high school college taking it to stick
it through.
Well,
I think it's a performance enhancing
drug.
So here's the question.
Is it worse than drinking?
I bet it isn't and we don't have any
problem with all those kids drinking.
The question is,
are they going to get addicted to it
more easily than they would get addicted
to drinking because you don't have this.
I mean,
I don't know,
but I'm assuming you don't have nearly
the same kind of hangout where right.
It was.
How,
how does it affect your liver in
comparison to like alcohol?
Because I think adderall and that kind
of shit.
Fuck might be worse in that aspect.
I think you'd see a lot of bodies if it
were.
I think there'd be a lot of dead people.
I really do.
This is what I think.
I think it's one of those where's the
body's thing like where's the bodies?
Whereas the bodies,
you know,
where are they?
It might be one of those things.
Oh,
you don't want to do lot of buddies
going to have to flex and Dolly,
oh,
are you sure you sure everybody's
already doing it.
Booze,
like there was a fucking stupid article
that I was reading about the Keto Diet.
It was so dumb.
He was so poorly written and uninformed
because they were talking about a study
they did where they took people and they
put them on a Keto diet for four days
and their athletic performance decreased
and then they even included the caveat
this could possibly be because of the
Keto flu,
which is something that sometimes people
get when their body goes into before
your body goes into Ketosis,
takes a long time to switch your body
off from a lifetime,
but burning carbs to burning fat.
The real health benefits in athletic
performance,
if any all happen after your body gets
through this transitionary period,
so they did a study about four days of
the Diet,
like who gives a shit?
Why would you do that?
That's not how it works.
It takes weeks before your body even
totally transitions over and then even
then the benefits and include increased
rather over months.
Ms Dot plenty of science on this stuff,
like the people that have had on the
podcast that talked about it like Dom
D'agostino and all the studies that he's
done on it.
Uh,
Peter Attia,
who's on the other day,
he's like real scientists who are like
the,
the data's out there.
You could look at it.
It doesn't work for everybody in terms
of the benefits of it,
but you don't do it over four days.
Like why?
So they're saying it's dangerous.
Potentially dangerous dive.
It's fucking food.
It's not dangerous.
You know what's really dangerous?
Eating the same way most people eat
every day.
You know what I was while I was watching
a video with this guy from,
you know,
the company called Flavor God.
I've seen that.
It's a spice company.
He makes really delicious spices.
And he had this video.
He went to a store and he just picked
out a garlic salt,
like,
okay,
let's try this one right here.
And he picks it up and it says sugar in
it.
Sugars,
third ingredient in fucking garlic salt.
So I go home after I watched this video,
I pick up the car.
So I'm like,
that looks like the shit that I have in
my house.
I pick it up.
It's under garlic salt.
It has fucking loves sugar.
It's like the third or fourth ingredient
is sugar.
I'm like,
you gotta be kidding me.
They put sugar in garlic,
salt these monsters.
That's insane.
That's not right dude.
These monsters.
Is he selling it as a spice or is it say
garlic salt on it says regular.
It's a big company.
It's a green cap.
It says garlic salt.
His stuff is just garlic and salt and
real spices and whatever.
This flavor God guy.
So he's just pointing out like,
look man,
you're getting fucked over.
And I didn't know.
I had no idea I was pouring this dye.
Put this stuff on my eggs.
I didn't know there's sugar in it.
That's ridiculous.
Why would you put sugar in garlic?
Salt?
You've got the.
Don't call it garlic salt.
Then call it Tony Spices.
This is Tony Spices.
I put a little of this.
I put a little of that.
You know what I like?
My grandmother always put sugar in
everything.
Fuck it.
Sugar.
It seems like that should be illegal.
It should be illegal.
Fucking asshole.
Because if.
What?
If you can't have sugar,
never think to look and check every
fucking label to make sure someone's not
sneaking some sugar in on you.
Creepy fucks.
Speaking and creepy fucks.
Did you hear about that nurse who is
going to jail because she was infecting
patients with HIV,
with Hepatitis C.
She was infecting her hepatitis c blood
into their medication.
Why?
Well,
she's crazy.
She's crazy.
She was giving them Hep c on purpose is
what they're alleging.
At least here it is.
Nurse allegedly used her own drug
needles on patients leading to hepatitis
C infections.
Okay,
so I'd read it differently.
I'd read that she injected the
medication with her blood.
She had put her blood in the medication.
Maybe that was just a shitty article I
read,
but either way.
Okay,
so what they're saying is
she's suspicious of two counts of second
degree assault.
She's not been formally charged and our
mother Eunice told the media at the news
conference prior to that,
her daughter wouldn't hurt a bug.
Hmm.
So say a Washington emergency room
nurses accused of stealing narcotics and
injecting to hospital patients with Hep
c using the same needles that she used
to inject herself.
Okay.
So the not saying she infected it with
her blood,
their blood on purpose.
She just did something super
irresponsible and used her needles on
these patients.
So what she did was.
So what they're alleging is that she's
using narcotics and she would get too
much for the patients and give some
theirself and they use that same needle
to give it to the patients probably
because needles are tightly controlled
because they don't know.
They probably have to account for every
needle missing so they don't give them
the junkies and they probably have to
account for all the narcotics.
So she would probably give them some of
hers since as she intentionally
contaminated medicine or other substance
with her own blood.
See,
that's what I read.
this is a different thing.
This is a different website you just
pulled out intentionally contaminated
medicine or another substance with their
own blood.
Then she administered the medicine,
medicine or other substance
intravenously.
So the way she did it wasn't by putting
her blood into the medication on
purpose.
The way she did it was by taking some of
their medication allegedly.
So I haven't seen any evidence that she
would have that would prove that she
intentionally infected anyone.
Hmm.
It's her attorney.
Yeah,
that's her attorney.
Yeah.
Um,
so we'll go to the top because there was
something about narcotics,
right?
I've read this.
There's a book called dead doctors don't
lie and it's all about this Guy Dr Joel
Wallach,
and it was all about mineral deficient
diets.
And then how many people are mineral
deficient diets because us farmlands are
just a totally overrun with,
uh,
you know,
you use the same land over and over and
over again.
They're overrun from the crops,
like just drained the dirt.
So they have to add minerals to the soil
and they have to add shit to it.
And this guy,
Dr Joel Wallach,
was talking about how you have to
realize like there's a lot of people out
there that over time mineral deficient
diets will show poor health results,
right?
So he was going on about how little
doctors know about health in general,
you know,
how to fix things,
but how little many doctors know about
like good diet and what's important,
what kind of nutrients really need
because they really don't spend that
much time in school,
much less time than the average person
who sort of obsessed with it.
But then he started going on about how
many doctors they find dead from
overdoses and stories about doctors that
just shot themselves up in a break room
and tie shot lock themselves up in a
bathroom and shot coke.
Like if they're that tired and that worn
down and they have access to coke,
I bet I bet a lot of them did it.
Especially when you could get.
If you get away with it,
especially if they have that liquid.
And in the hospitals they're probably
just huffing that stuff too.
They still have that liquid coat.
They have lidacain right.
But they have liquid.
What do they use the liquid coq for?
For a numbing agent.
Right.
Well that's what Lidocaine is.
Right?
Same thing though,
but I don't think a lot of king gets you
high.
I know this girl that used to,
I don't know if she made it,
but I always thought it was from a
doctor.
It was like an inhaler type thing and
she would just do that some or.
No,
no,
it was a nose thing.
Like a sprayed nose thing.
Like a flonase.
Flonase for coke.
Yeah.
And she would just do that and she would
like was just shoot liquid cocoa butter
smell.
Yeah.
Whoa.
That sounds better for you.
Then snort and I don't know,
it's like moisturizing.
The best way is apparently chew those
leaves.
You ever done that?
No,
I've never even seen that before.
Yeah,
the coca leaves.
That's apparently the best way,
but you never get that.
That's super rush.
It's like the difference between the
sugar that you would get from an apple
and the sugar you would get from some
koolaid.
Like you drank a gallon of coolant,
homemade koolaid.
We dumped extra sugar in there and stir
that bitch up.
Do you remember that?
How great was that?
Koolaid is.
Delivers your color.
What was your Goto?
I've never met a cool edit it in like
I never drank.
One glass of Koolaid was like,
this is bullshit.
That green one was always weird.
They're fucking great.
I loved when the big guy with the
pitcher burst through the wall to EU
Koolaid Cooler.
Just smash your house to give you.
He was so excited to see you and give
you the sugary drink.
It would break your fucking house.
I did.
Still around the Koolaid guy.
Is he on the.
On the package is still?
Yeah.
That'd be funny if they made them
thinner though,
you know,
to to like promote like no sugar or
something like that.
Like the change of time.
Get them on diet pills.
Get kool aid on the Diet pills.
The shot glass now had a adderall.
Adderall.
Okay.
Let's find out.
How many people die every year from
adderall.
Let's guess.
I'm going to guess I'm going to guess
less than a hundred.
Oh No,
no.
It's way more than that.
I'd say less than a hundred.
$100 in this country every year.
That's what I say.
I say 59 people die of adderall a year.
I'll say $21,000.
It would be the worst test ever on the
price is right.
It's just the chance you're taking.
Don't have to go that high.
Go a little higher than when you got it.
All right.
How much have you saved?
Fifty nine people.
Sixty nine.
What do we got?
Jamie?
The first thing I found that said that
there were 12 deaths associated to seven
to 16 year old boys in the year.
Two thousand five and there's like
articles about sudden death and 12 kids
on adderall.
So just 12.
Yeah,
but that's like it's not showing for the
year.
I don't know why.
I think when you die on adderall,
they know where you live.
They come down,
they nuke your house,
that kill all the witnesses.
Nobody this money and adderall must be
through the roof.
Well,
look at what to happen to cbd.
Did you hear about this?
Like I bet they have,
like the medicine companies have
something to do with that.
They just made it a schedule one for
CBD.
Did they really do that?
I thought they abandoned on that.
I just read it the other day,
a quarter with Kratom to courtrooms.
CBD scheduled one compound.
Cannabinol sales only were pot legal.
Well that's just stupid cbd.
It's got the most minor levels of thc
and it has a definite benefits,
especially when you put it on as a
lotion.
That stuff feels like a court.
Appeals Court upholds cbd status as
controlled substance.
Well fuck you appeals court as against
the hemp industry also.
Right?
That's a huge hit to him.
Cross the board.
It's a huge hit to humanity.
It's just dumb.
That stuff's great for old ladies.
With arthritis,
it's so much better than a lot of
medications.
You can take it in so many different
forms.
You could take it as drops.
You could take it as a spray.
I take it as a,
um,
an ointment that I'll put on,
like I have a sore shoulder or some
shit.
You can put that stuff on.
It's fucking great.
I just got,
got some recently and my anytime that my
neck is sore from like laying weird or
being in a hotel with a shitty pillow,
I put on like two minutes,
just loosens everything up.
It's amazing.
You know what?
I bet it would be great for like a
massage.
Maybe we'd get fucked up too high.
So I'm gonna give you a massage.
And CBD Lotion.
I did it the other day and I got it in
her vagina and I thought it was gonna be
bad.
Like I was like,
oh maybe I shouldn't have done that.
And you know,
it was fine.
Oh that's good.
But they,
they uh,
this company,
cbd for life,
they gave me all these,
like they face lotions,
they have the stuff you put underneath
your eyes.
Like they have so much different kinds
of cbd stuff.
Yeah.
Gino gave me some blue stuff.
It's like a roll on roll on deodorant.
You put it on like a sore elbow or
something.
It's great.
Yeah.
It's doesn't do anything bad to you.
The fact that these assholes decided
that it'd be a good idea to make that
illegal,
so dumb.
If there's nothing wrong with it,
it reduces inflammation.
It's healthy.
That's it,
period.
It doesn't do anything wrong,
so now you can't buy it anymore.
By and places where it's legal,
like we could still buy it because we
don't live in the dark ages because a
lot of dark ages states out there.
Do you ever watch that show?
A live pd?
I think it's called.
It's one of my favorite shows,
but it's so weird watching people get
busted for like weed and you're like,
wait,
how old is this show?
Oh,
it's live right now.
This is happening in and Ms Dot
Karolina.
Yeah,
there's a bunch of spots we could still
get like fully arrested.
Go to jail.
You're a criminal Texas for pot.
Yeah,
Texas.
They arrested.
Willing.
Nelson do.
They pulled Willie Nelson Office.
Tour bus,
you know,
that's like shooting a bass and a toilet
bowl.
That's so dumb.
It's so dumb.
How could you do that?
National treasure man.
Assholes.
Of course he smokes pot.
He's a hundred and 50,000 years old.
He's been playing music all across this
land forever.
Leave the guy alone.
Let him do whatever he wants.
He's Willie Nelson.
I mean,
if you don't love Willie Nelson,
fuck you.
Right.
Even if you don't want to listen to the
guy's music,
you like.
No.
Right now,
man.
I'm in this Amanda,
m and m right now.
Okay.
I get it,
but if you're like,
man,
fuck Willie Nelson.
No,
fuck you.
What do you think of the Kanye Shit
going on?
Jamie's kept me fully informed.
He talks about every morning.
Jamie has got many,
many theories.
He's got one of those mind boards.
Is Housewares kept index cards leading
to the center?
Yeah.
Kanye record releases in the center and
then all these things spray out to
yeezys and and flip flops and all these
slides.
Slides and he's got a bunch of theories
along the way.
I've never heard of your theory,
but does it involve the car accident
that he had right before he became
popular that like,
I think he has brain damage from this
car accident,
that those are the people that honestly
think that he is still on.
He.
Sorry,
he said he was on opioids from a getting
a light hypo actually because a lot of
the uh,
media scrutiny on them being fat,
he said let them to go getting light
bulb,
which led them to having a painkiller
addiction and he was on an opioid thing
and he was very afraid when he went to
the psych hospital that he was going to
get killed and people are going to take
them away for all the shit he was
saying.
So he did have some issues and I think
he's publicly said he has been on some
other,
um,
medication.
So he might be on or off of it right
now.
Well also he should definitely run for
president then scoop.
I mean,
now he's in.
It's perfect.
It's got all the right ingredients as an
artist.
That's just an artist,
but not.
I would take cognac over trump.
Any data.
Here's that thing that you do.
You're out of your mind.
Here's that thing that you just said
though,
about the accident.
You know,
that's the story of Sam Kinison as well.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Sam kinison was,
uh,
when he was a boy,
he apparently was like super normal kid
and then he got hit by a car really bad.
And um,
from that point on he became a different
person.
Kim,
wild and reckless and crazy.
It's the,
it's the football players get their head
hit
murder their wife,
Oj Simpson.
Um,
you know,
his doctor said that they would use that
as a defense.
They would consider using that as a
defense if that trial trials to happen
today.
One hundred percent.
It's like that other guy.
The guy ended up killing himself if had
the football player,
mark was his name.
Uh,
he went to jail and he hung himself.
Martino.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
Adrian,
what's his name?
Jamie Hernandez.
Aaron Hernandez.
That's right.
Yeah.
But they're saying that he probably
had that to 100 percent.
One hundred percent.
It's not a matter of whether or not you
have brain damage,
it's a matter of how much,
how much do you have and can you work
with it,
you know?
That's what I mean.
If you get hit in the head a lot,
you have brain damage.
Your brain does not want to get hit.
It's just not normal.
Aaron Hernandez suffered from most
severe ct ever found in a person his
age.
He's kind of like brandon shop here.
Looks like it looks like Brendan's way
more Quito right now.
Very a brain like isn't someone younger
than someone for 46 years,
like 25?
Yeah.
Dude,
I'm telling you.
There is a fucking epidemic.
This shit,
and it includes all sorts of people that
get their head hit.
Whether it's a bmx guys that are
constantly crashing.
When you think about how many times bmx
guy will crash in his career,
how many head head bumps he takes 'em
skateboarders,
notorious for doing crazy shit wiping.
You know what I mean?
The older you get the kind of like a pit
bull,
does it swell and it gets worse?
No,
no.
They do say though,
the damage that cumulative,
it's a cumulative cumulative over I
think a period of like 10 years from the
initial incident.
So like say if you have a really bad car
accident,
your brain will continue to deteriorate
for 10 years from the effects of that
accident.
Uh,
when,
when the guy told me that I was like,
how do you know?
And I don't know how they know.
I don't remember.
He kind of explained it,
but I was like,
wait,
so you mean a guy who gets knocked out?
We were at the fights when he was
telling me this.
So I'm like,
you tell me a guy who gets knocked out
today,
it's going to feel the real
repercussions of that knockout in 10
years.
He's like,
yes.
It's very possible.
That's the case.
Wow.
That's gonna take 10 years to show it's
full effects.
So if you see someone who's fucked up
now,
like if they've got brain damage now,
like as time goes on,
it's going to be like,
like Muhammad Ali was one of the weirder
ones because he had developed a
neurological disease.
He developed Parkinson's.
But there's,
there's trauma induced Parkinson's.
It's a lot of people try to say,
no,
I'll.
He got Parkinson's.
It was a disease.
Yeah,
maybe.
But you know,
who else has Parkinson's?
Freddie Roach,
the boxing coach,
and he openly discusses the fact that
it's trauma induced.
He got it from his long boxing career.
Just because it's a brain disease
doesn't mean the brain disease didn't
come from getting the fuck beat out of
your brain.
I mean,
imagine if you had a game that you
played or people like to kick you in the
liver.
This is the game,
you know,
you kicked me in the liver,
I kick you in the liver and then later
on you develop liver cancer and people
like.
Yeah.
But he used to like to drink.
Oh,
he had sclerosis had nothing to do with
getting kicked a lot.
Oh,
okay.
Nothing to do.
I'm sure he has a super healthy brain
after getting pounded on for decades.
That's ridiculous.
That doesn't make any sense.
Jesus.
Yes.
Dude.
I have the probably the most minor of
brain damages.
President most minor because I stopped
when I was 21.
Yeah.
What's your number?
How many times I got hit and now I'm
eating like how many times do you think
that you like,
oh,
that did damage.
Oh,
100 percent.
There's a bunch of them.
There's a bunch of them that I could
think back.
Getting rocked and filling my knees go
like getting punched in and then keeps
borrowing heaps.
Barring spar,
two more rounds.
That guy spar three rounds with another
guy.
He's hitting you in the face too,
like you didn't stop.
It was really dumb.
He'd get hit and you get rocked and you
didn't.
Nobody likes sat you down and go,
okay,
let's take the day off.
I know you get right back in there,
man.
You're fucking legs would go bang.
Let your legs would go.
When you cover up and you know people be
throwing bombs on you and you'd next day
sparring again.
Can you.
Is there a way to detect it?
Like at your brain scan?
So there are ways now.
There's better ways now,
but I had a limited amount of it.
I mean,
I had the real getting wrapped in the
head for me came when I tried to
transition from taekwondo to kick boxing
or doing taekwondo.
I got it.
I definitely got hit in the head for
sure,
but I didn't get hit in the head as much
because it's hard to kick people in the
head.
You definitely get hit.
I mean,
I don't know how many times I definitely
got hit,
but I never got knocked out from a head
kick butt.
I got knocked out from punches before at
least Tko Tko.
But when when a punch hits your face,
it's like your,
your legs go.
Everything shuts off.
Like if you get rocked and you,
you see like a person go down.
It's not that they go down like,
oh,
so much pain.
I have to go down.
No,
you get hit and everything shuts off.
It just goes better.
And then you feel your legs like
rubbery.
Trying to stand back up.
Did you just watch the last UFC where
Edson Barboza head kick.
Kevin Lee.
See that spinning wheel kicked him and
you see Kevin Lee's legs just go blank.
They just gave out for a second and then
he came back and
those those ones I got way more when I
was boxing.
She got way more of those like I was.
I was not good at boxing.
When I first got into boxing,
I was learning.
I was good at taekwondo,
but then I got into boxing.
I was not good at it.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I didn't understand the distance.
Taekwondo,
you didn't punch in the face and we
punched the body so you had a real
distorted perception of how good you
were with your hands.
And then once I started boxing I was
like,
Ooh,
this is terrible.
That's what I was taking like probably
the most damage of my life of a period
of like two years of like a lot of
sparring,
did a lot of sparring.
Everybody's sparred everybody's bar with
everybody.
People knocked people out all the time.
This is stupid.
So stupid.
I see guys get knocked out.
I mean out cold,
right hand to the chin,
boom.
Eyes rolled behind their head.
Legs give out,
they bounce off the canvas,
they put a cold towel on him,
they put some ice on his head.
He gets out and he's like,
I'm good.
You want to keep going?
Yeah,
let's keep going.
Let's keep going.
Now you would just unconscious you just
unconscious five minutes ago and you
want to keep spar and this is crazy.
And they let him,
they let him keep spar.
You did it from when you were like
really young,
right.
Taekwondo from when I was wide took
karate classes when I was 14,
but when I got super serious I was 15.
I was like right at my before my
sophomore year of high school.
So like I got into it from the time I
was in the uh,
ninth grade as I was 14.
Like that summer,
like right after my birthday around is
when I started getting into.
So it was probably either 14 or just
turning 15.
Asked like was there a point you could
tell where people actually could be able
to knock people out and give that damage
because there may be 14 year olds could
knock you out a little time here.
The thing about kicks is almost anybody
can knock you out.
It's really crazy.
Like when you think of the amount of
power that you have to have in your
legs.
Let's say if you decide to put a heavy
backpack on like one of those
outdoorsmen atlas trainers and put 90
pounds on,
you could walk up flights of stairs.
Dude,
just think of how much power that is in
your legs.
You could throw your body up,
flights of stairs for exercise just to
boost your body is whatever you way
1:50,
200,
whatever you way your body's just
launching that through the air over and
over and over again.
Even if you're a girl that weighs 135
pounds,
you're still launching 135 pounds
through the air,
and if that girl fucking shins,
you both hang right on your temple.
It goes across the jaw temple area.
Got Blind,
your legs are going to give out,
your brain's going to shut off if
somebody hits you.
Perfect.
There's a video of A.
I think the guy was she,
I think it was,
I think it was mighty Mo.
Mighty mo,
who's this huge kickboxer I believe he
was samoan and I mean just like typical
simone dude,
big giant fucking powerhouse of a dude.
And he fought his little thai guy.
This thai guy was 175 pounds,
so Much smaller than them.
I mean it was crazy to watch and tie
guys just we went away and moving away
and moving away.
And then the thai guy roundhouse kicks
hiM in the head.
This guy like,
look at the difference in size.
Yeah.
And watch this.
This dude just comes over the top.
I mean the difference between the two of
them.
Mighty mo is a beast to seriously
dangerous knockout puncher.
He put a lot of guys to sleep,
so not as this guy in there with someone
way bigger than him,
but he's in there with a killer.
But look at that one head kick and
mighty most down and out.
The back that up again because that is a
crazy thing to watch.
You're talking about a guy who might
have been a hundred pounds lighter than
him and mighty mole.
It's just a vicious puncher.
Bang.
You just clanged them right in the head.
That's what I'm talking about.
Girl.
Does that to you?
Night night son.
I was thinking more like 2:10 year olds
like no,
knock each other out.
That's a good point because the thought
process is that if you teach kids
technique,
don't teach them.
They just go in these wild fucking
haymaker exchanges,
but teach them how to do it correctly.
It's good to do it when they're young
because they don't hurt each other
because they have little tiny arms and
they just kind of touch each other and
they can't really generate knockout
power.
They just sort of.
If they learn how to do that from the
beginning and then develop knockout
power and the pads and on the bag,
then you develop much more technically
proficient fighters rather than
brawlers.
So the problem with fighting is like
most people don't fight to the physical
ability of their body.
Like they,
they just,
they decide they're going to knock thiS
guy out,
I'm gonna try to hit him with this and
they think in this real limited sort of
linear,
aggressive,
like almost obvious manner.
and then you got guys who see past that
who take thIngs to a new place.
You got guys who,
who figure out that you can be like
really elusive and confusing and then
you see those guys fight like limited
blocky,
like obvious fighters.
and like anderson silva and his prime is
a perfect example that anderson was an
artist.
I mean he would just,
he would,
you didn't know what he was going to do.
Its study you.
He'd be moving around,
maybe be standing in front of you.
He'd be dancing.
He just be following you around.
And then all of a sudden he just say,
I got this motherfucker figured out.
He would just move in on your bank and
you didn't know what was coming.
Flying knee.
You didn't know what was coming.
Roundhouse kick front kick to the face.
He didn't know what the fuck was coming,
man.
It was a totally different kind of
fighter,
so the difference between that and a guy
was just like a powerhouse of a person
and can knock guys out,
but never,
never achieves this sort of mastery of
space and distance.
They win fights through brawling and
power and just kinetic brute force
rather than artistry and avoidance and
countering like conor mcgregor,
one knocked out josé aldo.
Perfect example.
All those like fuck you charge and
connor slides back,
bop drops a fucking left hand on the
button,
pop up and he's the champ champ.
I mean,
come on champ.
Then became the champ champ champion
that,
you know,
that thing is,
it's hard to figure out.
Sometimes guys just decided to it rather
bite down your mouthpiece and let the
fucking chips flying.
It's not fun as part of that and have a
fight just like the last 30 seconds,
30 seconds,
and I just throw it out like crazy
because they know there's no more time
left.
Yeah,
they just try to.
When I try to try to stop it.
Yeah,
some of those fights are awesome.
Look as a,
as a person watching those things are
awesome.
There's two different parts.
The way I look at fights,
like I love a good diego sanchez,
gilbert melendez fight where they just
fucking go crazy for three rounds.
I loved that.
ThAt was one of my favorite fights ever,
but I also love real technical fights
where I see,
I see like two artists trying to solve
each other's riddle,
trying to figure each other out.
You know,
like luke rockhold versus yoel romero.
Was that like yolo?
Just trying to figure him out,
trying to figure him out.
Maybe I move like this and then boom
drops that left hand on them.
Same thing with him versus chris
weidman.
He just moving around.
It's hard to figure out what he's going
to do.
Hard to figure out what's coming and
then wome flying knee To the chin or to
the head.
He's a.
He's a great example of a guy just
figures out how to break your rhythm and
figure it through rather than just
running a.
Because clash,
clash,
clash.
You know,
frank mir was jusT talking about that
fate or fight and he was saying That his
ego got the best of them.
Did you see the fight?
It's really good.
Fight really crazy until feta or keto
them fade or cut on with the lefthand
and dropped it and put them away.
But before fate or k owed him,
frank mir had hit fate or and it got
interesting in the very beginning
seconds of the fight,
but then fate or hit him with a
perfectly timed hip throw,
just fucking boom.
I mean sent him flying through the air
and slammed him to the ground.
And apparently frank said from that
moment on his ego got the best of me
trying to get them back and then he
wound up just getting this crazy brawl
and getting knocked out.
It's really fighting to me.
So it's so interesting.
You know,
it's just so interesting when you see
all the different things that people can
do and how they're going to match up
together and how,
what one person's going to be able to
figure out how to get their,
their ideas through my ideas.
I want to kick this motherfucker in the
head.
How can I do this?
I've got to figure out how to get there
and his ideas.
I want to take this guy down and punch
his fucking face in.
How do I figure out how to do this?
And then the two of them are just like
trying each other's strat and you don't
really know.
You don't fucking know.
You don't know until they get in there.
For the most part
its greatest shit ever.
Have they with the judging?
Have they ever tried like I'm sharing in
between rounds what the scores are so
you don't have to guess it was through
rocks that those people.
What if they don't say who it is or they
don't have to be a bad idea?
They killed them all just by being
associated.
What if they weren't there?
What if they're like in the back room or
oh,
that's even worse.
Why aren't you there?
Maybe the judging would be better if
they were there.
They have to be there
in person judging.
They're actually elevated.
They're a little higher than everybody
else too.
They're looking at it like above me
because it would have like when there's
a,
when the accident happening on the other
side of the octagon,
you can't see anything,
so I know they didn't get a monitor,
but like if they should,
what's the point being we can't.
We gotta make sure they got monitors.
They didn't get monitors in the
beginning.
In the olden days they didn't have
monitors and I,
I was going crazy.
I was like,
how is it that I,
a person who has no effect whatsoever on
the score of this fight?
I have a monitor I can ask for for
replay.
I have all this shit at my disposal.
I have,
I have earphones on with a microphone
and I could press the truck.
I go,
can I see that again?
And they'll show it to me on the screen.
LIke guys,
his ankle broke and so the production,
like sometimes during a fight we'll tell
them,
hey joe,
we got head,
but it was a head but that caused that
cut.
And then I'll say,
okay,
I'm just hearing from the truck now that
it was a head button.
We're going to show you that as soon as
we can,
but I'm watching it on the screen right
there.
Why can't the judges get that?
How long ago did that change?
It seems like they should have been in
table one.
It wasn't that long ago.
Wow.
I don't think the judges have access to
replays though.
They can't call up a replay like I can.
Why not?
They shouldn't be able to.
Should be able to have a little bit too
much time to judge or think about it or
no,
you need to know things.
You need to know things.
Like if a guy gets kicked in the balls,
was that a real kick in the balls?
Watch after the after the fact because I
just said you don't want their attention
taken from what's going on.
The action depends on replay.
Depends.
Yeah.
I mean I think it should just be an
option for something's up.
Like what happened there?
Did he get rocked or did he fall on his
ankle?
You know what I'm saying?
Like what happened there?
And there's only one way to tell.
Sometimes you got to see it again
because he that again,
please.
They should be able to say,
can I see that again,
please?
That would be as I said,
yeah.
Well they.
They have instant replays now,
which is interesting.
Like say if a guy pokes the guy in the
eye and the judge wants to call for an
instant replay,
but once they instituted the instant
replay in some states the fight is over.
That's so great.
That doesn't make any sense.
So if I say no instant replay,
I'll just take this.
I poke and keep fighting.
That's okay,
but if you want to look at it on video,
the fights over what?
I compare it to the mba,
which I watch a lot,
they go to the replay a lot,
which is a little annoying as a viewer,
but they're.
They're trying to get it right,
which they have a team of people in New
York where they're watching all the.
All the angles.
They can pull up anything they want.
They can see anything that they take as
much time as they need to.
Sometimes it takes five minutes,
but why not do that with fighting?
They get it right.
You know?
Common sense.
Why doesn't that exist?
It should definitely exist and I mean we
talked about it with Michael Chandler
yesterday.
There should be more.
Judges.
Definitely shouldn't be.
Only three judges.
That's.
It's ridiculous.
It doesn't make any sense.
There's no reason to limit it to three
judges.
I bet you would get far more competent,
far more knowledgeable judges for free
than you would even if you paid them.
Just pull up their fucking twitter cap,
blow the twitter account up.
They'll judge you for free to so many
mma fans out there that would love to
judge fights and they actually
understand fighting.
They really get it and they love it.
They're not just doing it because it's a
job and they used to do boxing and you
know this is a good way to make 1500
bucks on a saturday night or whatever
they met.
That's not what they're doing it because
they actually love it.
So many people,
but do it.
It will be way better.
You can definitely judge from home too.
We could definitely should have,
I mean why not have like an online
scorecard as well?
Like why not have that as an option so
the ufc could let everybody know how bad
the judges are.
I mean I'm not saying that everybody
online is going to know what the fuck
they're talking about,
but enough people online you going to
know what they're talking about where
it'll balance out.
So if you had just like 10 judges and
then the online judges have an online
store
work card.
If you pay for five pasture where you
probably are willing to have some
knowledge on the sport,
but also it put it in the app.
Say like conor fight unknown ob,
you know,
they're all the conor fans are going to
vote for him anyway.
Balance out because unknown bob will
probably have some fans too and then
people will be a bunch of haters.
They're hoping that connor failed
because he's got a limousine and bypass.
You got paid for your vote.
In that case,
you want to pay 10 bucks every time.
Yeah,
exactly.
Will you.
If you had an app,
you have a ufc app and the app,
all it has to do,
they just make it so it's interactive.
So with each fight,
after the fights over,
you click winner or loser,
you know that's all you have to do just
quick winter and you.
If you are optional,
you could put in your own score,
but the fuck out of here,
the scoring sucks anyway.
That 10 point must system stupid.
It's,
it's a borrowed system.
It's not a good system for all those
weapons.
It's a good system for two,
two weapons,
punches,
kicks and knees and elbows,
chokes,
takedowns defense.
You've got slams and throws and come on,
we'll kicks and spinning back kick.
What's better?
Spinning back kick or a jab
in boxing is a punch or a punch.
Like that punch was harder than that
punch,
but unless someone's kicking you in the
leg,
you don't even know what that feels
like.
You have no idea.
Guys just walking around like nothing
happened.
You can't score that.
If nobody's ever kicked you in the legs,
they should have a full body suit that
detects punches and that like how strong
it is within.
It takes away from the fucking.
The rawness of it all.
You can't have people fighting in body
suits.
One of the future.
It will look like you don't have
anything on.
A lot of gals have to where the weather
is something that covers their
midsection,
right?
They have like a sports bra strap down,
sort of jammy and they wear something
that covers her midsection to.
That's interesting.
Like they have to have their stomach
covered or they're allowed to have their
stomach covered just to keep their boobs
and check like everybody got to stay in
the party.
Can't fuck up those titties.
Cats and gone.
We'll be on soon.
She'll explain it to us because she had
a wardrobe malfunction.
One of her fights.
Really just a little snip at the docs
can
skip steps
in that funny.
Every dude shows his nipple every due to
fights shows his nipple girl goes out
and shows her nipple.
Everybody goes crazy.
It's funny.
Twitch,
twitch won't even let a grown man take
off his shirt stand.
Keep your clothes on.
You freak.
People are always like,
why don't you broadcast on twitch?
Because I,
if I can get banned for just showing a
nipple.
What else?
I mean,
anything a man can get banned.
Like bert kreischer,
if he tried to do the berg cast on
twitch,
which it immediately be a band.
He could maybe talk to them and they
might be able to.
But most people,
yeah,
it's against the guidelines to show skin
looks a lot of those things.
That's the only problem with twitter
that you forget.
It's made for babies.
So silly.
You can't show man boobs.
Yeah,
it's pretty readable.
You're super flat chested with you take
your shirt off and you just smooth.
I just don't want people taking their
shirts off there.
Okay.
what if you take your shirt off and you
have like pastries on.
I do have people that do body paint,
so there is a little bit of
body paints.
Okay.
So if you decide to do like,
um,
the british flag,
paint that over your body,
that's okay.
But you just can't be no paint
strip clubs in columbus,
Ohio.
The ones that serve alcohol,
they can't even show their tits.
They have to paste all these days,
but they have pastries that look like
better areolas,
you know?
Oh,
I'm going to have these nice darker ones
like fake patients.
Whoa.
Wow.
That's sick body pains.
Pretty cool when it's done.
Right.
That is incredible.
That's really good.
Go back to that again.
Yeah,
that's neat.
There's a couple of them missing this.
She's doing this character on the side
here.
Right.
But that's all her really.
I'm pretty sure.
Wow.
Well,
she's definitely got some kind of a boob
pad going on.
Wow,
that's amazing.
Some people are really good tour self.
Have you ever seen the girl I saw on
instagram where she will like,
will paint her eyes like up here and
then have like a fake nose and a fake
mouth and it looks like a completely
different face and then she opens her
realize you're like,
well that's that.
That's
her name though.
Yeah.
This is basically you're looking at
naked boobs.
They're just got paint on them.
So we let it slide.
So is this this girl's thing?
She just gets her boobs painted and it
goes onto.
Oh my god,
she does.
That's her thing.
That is hilarious.
That's great.
That's a way that you could see the
whole thing.
Girls are trying to figure out this
dress.
It's just not tight enough.
It's not revealing enough.
There were some girls that were playing
games on twitch just in like a bikini or
whatnot and they got in trouble for
that.
So they hAd to take their scheme over to
youtube or some other sites.
How long before someone comes up with a
nontoxic paint that girls can paint all
over their body and it's like a thin
nylon layer and they'll go ouT and
you'll see everything.
So you know there's going to be a few
girls that just go for it.
Like this deadpool here,
naked deadpool girl.
Like how there's going to be girls like
that that just go for it.
My favorite is if you google a twitch
girl desert,
realize camera's still on after show and
masturbates.
Is it telling you got busted,
fallen for that?
Come on,
you have all thought looked really real.
You just,
you just dream real.
You it to be real.
That's ridiculous.
Call bullshit on every call.
Bullshit.
So it's like a well known girl that did
it.
No.
Right.
Direct you on instagram.
What's your name?
Mary?
Nine zero four five.
And did you say hello dear?
Well,
no,
I mean look,
there was no reason why it was like a
bad,
like she was half off the camera.
Like it looked like it wasn't that her
sister would do it.
If I was going to fake something,
wouldn't you figure it out?
Right?
Come on son.
How dare you?
Just sad,
sad that you got roped into that.
I feel less of,
you know,
iT's the first time it's happened,
joe.
I,
there's so many scams is too easy to get
the new one.
I almost got scammed the other day.
They do want,
I don't know what's going on lately with
a robo calls,
but I'm,
I'm getting a call almost every day.
like this is the iris.
We are,
you need to contact us now.
And,
or this is a t and t you need to,
uh,
we need to talk to you about your
billing.
Please enter your credit card info right
now.
You'd like,
did they call you when you're high?
Nonstop?
No,
but,
uh,
it,
it's interesting because,
uh,
like I think t mobile does it.
How does your phone come up now?
It just a scam.
Likely like t mobile is now filtering
out these calls and it's telling me if
it's a scam like him.
Yeah,
I like that.
Are you going gonna be cool and say
murder spray that,
uh,
as the rest of the world that sort of
gets online.
Like for instance,
like parts of africa that aren't online
now will be online eventually that the
scams will switch back.
Like the nigerian prince scam will be
american scamming.
People in africa just get on because
they don't know about the scams yet
because they haven't been a part of it.
Oh my god.
I don't know if that really happened
with that.
Like some theories,
that's not a bad theory,
but those people were really good at
scamming lonely people.
There was such a sad show I was watching
once about this old guy,
I think the guy's daughter was like
trying to like tell him that this girl
wasn't real and he kept going to england
for.
We went to europe twice,
um,
to meet her and both times something
came up and she couldn't meet him.
Then he went back again and he keeps
sending her money.
He's been sending her money,
sent her,
I want to say like a quarter million
dollars.
And his daughter was like,
it's not written.
You could see the guy like,
like they're filming them and talking to
him and he had this look in his eye like
he was hoping the wrong,
but thinking they might be right.
Like he was going insane.
He was going insane from loneliness.
Sad.
I see it everyday on the web cam sites.
There's guys that every single day I go
there,
the same guys there and he's spending
money nonstop all day long and he's just
on there all day.
He might spend like thousands of dollars
a day.
How billion dollar internet scam is
breaking hearts and bank accounts,
criminal networks,
defraud,
lonely people around the world with
false promises of love and romance.
You know,
you could analyze this from a lot of
ways,
like it's predatory behavior.
I caught a coYote in my yard last night
was predatory behavior,
right?
It's going to have human coyotes.
You're Always going to.
I didn't catch him,
catch him,
catch him.
I just chased them out of my yard to try
and get my chickens.
But this is a predatory behavior on a
weak person,
you know,
so I can see it's on one hand I feel
upset that they would go after these
people,
these lonely people.
But on the other hand that's fascinating
to me was like,
what a drug people's love is what a drug
that is like how important it is that
people like find people that care about
them,
that like them and care about them.
IT's so important when you don't have
that in your life,
you just feel so empty and it's one of
probably the most major sources of like
bad feelings in people,
so they just don't have anybody that
loves them.
They don't get what good friends,
they don't have,
they don't have good people around them
and they just sad.
Just sad to the point where someone
comes along,
we can help you.
Come on,
come over here.
We've got girls.
Girls would want to meet you.
Curls in your town,
girls sign up.
You can meet girls like rules,
you know?
It's like someone,
someone offering you food.
Facebook's new online dating service
won't have ads.
I thought that said won't have
aids,
aids and that's what I said.
It was like,
what the fuck are they saying?
It sounds like that'll take advantage of
what you're talking about right now.
Online dating service won't have ads so.
But it will have russians all russians
all the time.
Well,
I mean it'd be nice if people could just
meet people in the real world.
ThIs meeting people online stuff.
It's so weird how,
like I talked to people that use tinder,
they hooked up on tinder like weekly and
there's a lot of these people that
that's all they do.
They'll just fuck people on tinder all
day.
It just makes you wonder how many people
just do that.
Like all data women and she's already
been fucked like seven times for the
same
app.
You know,
like all these people are just like,
they're just like,
you're taking extreme risks.
Yeah.
With your bed.
there was,
there was the
second thing where they wanted to do
online dating apps.
Like someone was saying,
should online dating apps be responsible
for the increase in sexually transmitted
diseases?
Should they be responsible?
Like as if they have some obligation to
tell you to wear rubber.
Oh fucking stupid.
That is like soMe,
they have some obligation.
They're like,
you know,
like look,
these poor little children are go
fucking.
He needed to tell them they need to
protect theMselves.
Like these adults wrote adults using an
app.
Tinder and grindr don't want to talk
about their role in rising stds.
Good.
Why do you want to talk to them?
You muck raking piece of shit.
They don't have a role.
They connect people together.
People make their own decisions.
You've got to be responsible for your
own actions,
especially when it comes to something
like that.
That's crazy.
And you know,
the other part is like the demonization
of sex is a part of this,
or what about tinder and grindr?
What are you doing here?
All these people is just having sex and
getting stds.
you're responsible.
What about your part?
What about your role?
Your kid out outta here.
That's ridiculous.
Do bars have a role in liver sclerosis?
Should they pay people out?
Should they be financially responsible?
They're literally selling you the shit
that kills you and they have zero
responsibility as long as they don't
serve you while you're drunk and driving
along as they cut you off in time and
said,
hey,
you got to drag.
We cut him off.
Alright,
sounds drug.
They literally sell you the stuff that
does it to you and no one cares as they
should.
No one should care.
You're fucking grown adult.
Does grindr,
those dudes banging each other all day?
Do you think that anyone's going to stop
that?
Oh,
I shouldn't connect these people.
You should make money connecting them.
You shouldn't give them the opportunity
to do exactly what they want as grown
adults with a limited about of time on
earth.
Get 90 years.
If you're lucky,
if you want to spend 45 of tHem raw dog
and dudes,
you go,
you go boy,
who gives a shit?
Are they respond?
They don't want to talk about their
responsibilities.
Shut the fuck up babies
now.
That very upset about something that was
new to me,
especially grinder now that backpage has
closed,
like all these websites are closing.
It's very interesting to see what
happens next where people are going to
find their hookups and stuff.
Well,
yeah.
That was what I was reading this thing
where sex workers are in danger because
of this,
because before they used to be able to
vet customers and then customers would
have like a record of using other sex
workers and they could know who the
psychos were,
who to avoid.
You know what I mean?
And they could also screened people like
actively screen.
They could do,
they could do all this.
they were saying,
I was reading an article about it where
this girl who remember if they gave her
name out or not,
but she was.
She worked in a brothel and she was
talking about it and it's like,
what?
Why are they doing this?
Like is there,
is it because of a crime?
what's the crime?
So if they get together like through
tinder or grindr,
that's fine because that's two people
that decided to have sex,
but as long as they're grown adults and
one person just wants to get paid and
the other person's like,
well I'll pay you.
And they go,
okay,
fine.
Like what?
Why is that illegal?
Like we're not talking about sex
trafficking for children.
We're not talking about slavery.
Were just talking about just let's just
look at it from the cleanest
perspective.
Possible grown adult who likes sex,
decides she wants to work in a brothel.
Is that possible?
Is it possible for you to do that?
Like for it to be a grown adult who
actually enjoys it?
Does have any problem with it decides
that it's better than working at
wendy's?
Isn't that?
Is that possible?
I mean,
the people don't want to say it.
Nobody wants to say that it's possible.
Nobody wants to ever look at it that
way.
The war on sex workers needs to stop
now.
Rolling stone.
Yeah.
It's.
It just seems like a dumb thing to chase
down.
I mean,
I think if people want to have sex with
each other,
nobody has a problem with it,
but if people want to pay people to have
sex,
then it's a problem.
That seems so crazy.
Again,
we're not talking about child slavery.
We're not talking about sex slaves.
We're not talking about anything against
anybody's will.
We're just talking about people who
would choose to do that.
Like why not?
And I've always used this example,
but it's a good example.
Why?
Why is it okay for me to get a massage?
it's okay for me to pay someone to give
me pleasure all over my body except my
genitals.
Like they could ruB my neck and my feet.
They can get it all.
All been my feet,
man.
They get those thumbs and start working
your feet.
Uh,
they crack your toe pop.
Pop.
It feels great.
That's fine,
but they can't jerk you off.
They jerked you off.
That'd be a terrible sin against god.
And man,
if they touched your penis,
which feels really good when you touch
it,
can't do that.
I know a dude who said he gets asked
whole massages.
Yeah.
That actually happens all the time to be
terrier of your asshole.
They massage the interior of your
asshole.
That's okay because it's just a massage.
Prostate massage with weird is when they
do it and they don't ask you because
there's a lot of massage.
People just do it.
That's a part of the massage and they
just started.
Yep.
No,
no,
no.
I don't want that.
Apparently some people get it,
whether they use a tool and they
actually go in side.
Your ass hole rubbed down.
No,
no,
no.
That's that tool.
The other one,
you're fis,
fis,
they use some sort of a thing to fucking
check your,
but that's okay.
That's fine.
Just don't touch the dick.
If you touch the dick,
it's goddamn crime.
They're waiting outside the door with a
pistol.
you just let me know when he touches the
dick.
He's just rubbing his asshole.
Check the books,
so.
All right.
Oh,
it's not even hard.
Okay.
we're ready.
We're ready.
We're going to break it.
This fucking shady place.
Soon as we find out that he's dick
touched like you could get someone to
just massage your asshole.
JusT get in there with squeeze your butt
cheeks and get two thumbs in your ass
on.
Am I doing?
I'm doing a sphincter massage.
It's very important to release some of
the shock rose and negative energy and,
and,
and some of the toxins that are stored
in your body from processed foods and a
modern lifestyle.
So we're just going into your asshole.
But to dump some guru talked people into
filming them in the ass.
So weird that I've never.
Like I just recently found out all that
shit that's happening in massage
parlors,
but like,
you know,
10 years ago I had no clue.
I would go buy a massage part and go,
oh,
that's of massages.
There's nothing bad going on here.
I wonder how many places like that are
like,
like psychics,
what happens at psychics at four in the
morning?
Why are they open at four in the
Because that where you get your ass eat
and out and I.
You don't learn about that until you're
70 or something.
I don't think so.
Think psychics are open late at night
because a,
it's a scam and be when people are,
it's late at night.
They're drunk and like maybe it's the
girls driving home.
The guy texted her and she doesn't know.
Should I text him back?
Why is he texted me so late?
That's kind of disrespectful.
I don't know if he's the one that she
pulls into that psychic's office and
she's like,
I just need you to tell me about my
future and the psychic because like I
sense there's a problem and romantic
interest.
My boyfriend.
Yes.
There's your stressed.
There's something deeply troubling you.
Your,
you're confused.
I am confused.
Yes.
You're confused.
You trying to the decisions hard to
something coming up.
Something's happening.
Can you ask me to come over to the house
and fuck it?
Yes.
That's it.
There's a thing that he's wanting you to
do.
The.
You're not so sure if he's the one.
Is that a yes?
Oh my god.
That's what I said when I was on the way
over here.
And then when he said,
you're not sure if he's the one.
I'm like,
oh my fucking god.
Is it like written on my forehead?
How's it possible?
He knows.
He fucking knew about mark.
He knew about our relationship problems
and he knew that I was on my way over
there wondering whether or not he's the
one.
Yeah,
I don't think he's still.
I think you're my favorite girl voice
guy.
You know,
like I,
you fucking asshole
and all this bullshit with.
I'm trying to figure out how this
fucking psychic knows the one for me.
Who does this?
No,
she,
no
friend of mine went to one.
It's like he knew my grandmother's home.
Everything about my relationship.
My grandmother.
I go,
don't you know,
don't you know everything about your
relationship with your grandmother.
What the fuck you want?
Do you want to pay people to tell you
shit you already knew it's 4:00,
4:00.
You're fucking nuts.
I'm wearing a watch.
Uh oh.
My brains out.
You get wet.
Oh,
this guy's crazy.
tell me all this shit.
I already knew.
It's crazy.
I bet.
I bet it's psychics are way better now
nowadays because of technology and like
they probably have like little earpiece
in,
some guy in the back like looking at
their license plate number online and
finding out where they live,
you know,
like the and just feeding the person
information.
I bet psychic are killer now.
I bet there's some probablY they're like
super high scammy level
because you want to repeat customer,
so if you're that accurate habit,
there's a huge scam that that is a crazy
thing if you're driving,
if you're driving to burbank or some
shit every couple miles to see one of
those psychic reader places.
Five in the morning
open big hand on the front,
like a hand job place.
But it's a psychic.
I went to one once when I was in New
York and I was going to these fucking
stupid auditions.
I did not want to act and I was going,
I was just wasn't what I was interested
in doing,
but like your agency would tell you,
well,
you know,
you really should look into this and
you'll see what it was.
It was like some role that not only was
I not going to get it,
but I want it like this is like,
it's not even funny.
It's like super serious.
Yeah,
but you should do it.
So they just,
they know,
they know what.
You could do commercials that go in and
read for commercials and I'd be like,
what the fuck am I doing?
So I left one of them and I was terrible
at it too.
It was terrible auditioning.
And then I went to this,
um,
I went to this psychic and I'm like,
well,
fuck it.
Let's say it's only like,
I don't remember how much it was,
like five bucks,
10 bucks.
She's like,
you don't get along with your brothers.
I go,
I don't have any
brother's shit.
I left her,
you don't know anything like looked in
her eyes and she looked at it,
me and I knew that.
She knew that.
I knew she was full of shit.
I looked at her.
I don't have any brothers.
She was like,
oh shit.
I got crazy.
She got gangster.
She took a swing.
Just like sensing brothers from this
asshole could chip on the shoulder.
Shoulder brothers probably beat them up.
no,
it came from a bad audition.
You missed it.
It's weird how we all know it's bullshit
for the most part.
There may be some weirdo that actually
can do some shit,
but like,
but we still accept it.
People still go to it even though they
know deep down like,
hey,
we have a gun to your head right now.
Is this real?
If you do the wrong answer,
then we're going to blow your head off.
Everyone's back.
No,
it's not real.
Even the people that believe psychics
the most are going to say,
no,
it's not real.
What did you say?
most likely if it comes to a bullet in
the head,
right,
so like,
but we still do it like or crystals.
Oh no,
these crystals are healing me.
oh yeah.
Gun to the head.
Do you think they're really healing?
Do you think this rock is healing?
You know?
No.
You know,
no one's goIng to say yes.
Well here's the.
But those crystals,
those magnet things and all that shit.
That one weird thing is the placebo
effect.
Placebo effect is real.
It's very real.
Do you remember those holograms that
people were wearing for awhile on those
rubber bracelets?
Yeah.
Brody has like four of them.
Dude.
There was world class ufc fighters that
were wearing those stupid fucking things
like top of the food chain assassins and
they were like,
dude,
I'm telling you.
It's been helping my elbow.
Like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And I talked to one of the guys.
Goldberg was wearing one for awhile.
My buddy mike goldberg was wearing one.
I was like,
dude,
I don't think that's real.
I was like,
you don't think I go,
I don't think so.
He's like,
you want to meet with the guys who are
making a girl?
Okay.
I met with the guys who make it and they
try to do one of those a strength test
things on you,
like,
here's what I want you to do.
I'm to.
I'm going to put this rubber band on
you.
I want you to put your arms straight out
and I'm going to push down on it,
and they're like halfway push down.
This is one of those things.
It's like,
okay,
I'm trying to lift your arm up,
and they're like,
push down on your hand and then go,
okay,
now we'll put this rubber bracelet on
you.
Now try to lift your arm up like,
wow,
this is crazy.
I can lift my arm up because you weren't
holding it back.
You're not a machine.
Like you could regulate how much force
you're putting a.
Yeah,
I know what you're doing.
I go,
this is a goddamn carnival trick.
So I said to the guy,
go,
this is the goddamn carnival trick.
And goldberg was like,
is this fake?
I,
it's fake.
It's fake.
I go,
what is this?
you tell me how this works.
You have a piece of plastic,
but you're telling me I'm going to put
on a rubber band.
It's going to make me stronger,
dude.
Okay.
I didn't spend a lot of time in school,
but I spent enough.
Fuck you.
You can't do a hologram inside a
hologram.
Anyway.
Life is a hologram.
You can't.
It's all hog.
That's true.
They don't even exist.
There's certain things that make you
think it might be a hologram,
right?
Power scam.
That's it.
Power bounce.
Admits the wristbands or scam or wait a
minute.
No way,
bro.
We admit that there's no credible
scientific evidence that supports our
claims and therefore we engage in
misleading conduct.
Yeah.
I called that shit out in like 2001.
I was like,
what are you guys doing?
Like what is this?
Who's wearing that?
Why you weren't?
Why would you think that would work?
They had to published that in australian
media.
Yeah,
because Australia is fucking smarter
than us
because of their bogus claims and pseudo
scientific mumbo jumbo,
but this seems to be the first time in
which a regulatory authority has made
them admit their claims are simply a
fraud derp look,
there's some shit that makes you strong,
but it's not a rubber band with a piece
of plastic attached to it.
It cbd oil,
you know,
I mean,
you want something that makes you feel
better.
Cbd oils real well,
trying to make that illegal.
There is some,
uh,
some people that say that there's no
scientific proof that cbd,
even eggs works at that.
it's always,
it's always the other ingredients that
are mixed with the cbd,
you know,
like they'll take the same ingredients
that's in bengay and then put cbd in it
also.
And they say,
doesn't this feel numb now?
Like there's a lot of,
there's no real.
I heard that there was no real concrete
evidence that cbd because there's no
test.
I thought there was evidence that a
decreased inflammation.
Isn't there evidence that a decreased
inflammation?
The problem is the scientific studies,
all these things.
It might be,
I might be mind fucking myself when I
put that stuff on.
You might seem to work though,
especially for my elbow tendinitis.
I feel like it works.
Finally getting over dude.
I finally could do chin ups.
I couldn't do champs for months.
Months.
Try years.
Joe
up with this.
It'll help get cBd in it.
Um,
I,
I really,
I was,
I was not doing chin ups or anything
heavy.
I was doing mostlY running and yoga for
months because of this fucking elbow
I've,
I've never had tendinitis before.
I've had muscle poles and stuff and
injuries.
I never had tendinitis this and this was
a dumb one because I meet,
headed my way through it.
I need headed it into a bad place.
I go to like,
don't be a pussy,
just keep working out.
And then it got real bad and then it
until I did a bunch of different stuff
to it.
I did stem cells and regena keen,
but the thing that helped them also
this,
this rubber thing.
Oh,
is that roller?
No,
it's not.
It's called a,
a therm.
a band.
I've Talked about this so many times
that I can't therabands rather.
I can't buy them on amazon anymore.
People have bought them out,
but I'm glad because they work.
If you have a.
It's cheap too.
It's just,
it's just a piece of rubber and if you
don't have this and you have something
that can do a similar exercise,
it'll probably help too,
but what you do is you twist it and then
in the release,
hm.
Twisted.
Yeah.
You twist this thing and in the elite
you like to twist it with your hand like
this and then the release with the right
hand,
the right.
My right elbow is one that was injured
and just slowly letting it down.
It works.
This part of your arm.
Oh,
that's weird way.
So even thouGh it's injured,
it doesn't hurt it,
but it strengthens it.
That's great.
It works a lot,
so I'll just pick this fucker up and do
it 10 times,
12 times,
15 times and do it several times a day
and I made a big difference man.
Like right away I coulD feel it just.
It feels like everything around.
It's like strengthened and stabilized
and it just started feeling better
because you're putting a load on it and
then you make an it release the load
instead of like pulling it in the
direction that you injured it.
You're,
you're strengthening it in the,
I guess would be the eccentric way.
East centric.
Essentra quit.
Hm.
So there you go.
Don't get tendinitis.
Kids.
I had recently from I think using cell
phones too much and computers too much,
like carpal tunnel to the point where my
hand hurt.
Like I think it's the same shit.
It's repetitive stress.
Yeah.
Right.
Secretaries get that right from a lot of
typing and stuff.
Hairstylists also get it a lot.
Yeah.
Um,
and I know a tattoo artist and has it.
Yeah.
And it right now just me even saying it,
I'm like,
it's still actually really sore.
My hands go to guys who get it in their
risk too.
And um,
you know,
for a lot of those guys they start
getting addicted to antiinflammatories
and know different things to try.
Because if you have to use your fingers
for work,
imagine if you had to do something with
your hands like that for work and you
started feeling that pain.
Like this is just my elbow,
you know?
I meaN I can do pretty much everything.
But your hands,
like if it's in your hands,
fuck,
that's a bitch.
I was reading this article about
replacing body parts.
They were talking about all the
different body parts that are on the
verge of being able to replace.
He dId a face transplant,
didn't they?
They've done a few of those things.
Yeah.
They did a few dick transplants.
Cock and balls.
Yep.
here's the thing.
If they can't do the balls,
who wants the balls?
You don't need them.
But here's no.
But here's the thing for ethical
reasons,
because the dead person's sperm will
always be in those balls.
So here's the thing.
Say if you,
if you took my balls,
if I died and you took my balls and put
them into your body and they started
having kids,
those would be my kids.
They would have my genes.
You can have my come inside of your body
growing.
You got,
oh,
you're going to make my own comp.
You could,
but that's the crazy thing you could
make.
Jamie's come.
Jamie died and he donated his cock and
balls and you took his boy.
Put in your body.
You.
He would grow your company.
My company?
Yes.
Come.
It's his.
It's your balls.
So it's your sperm and your come you
your ges.
Let's just call it tj's,
but for scientific purposes,
what happens if I have one of your balls
and went to jamie's follows what
happens.
So I have a.
We have a fucking crap shoot.
Who the hell that kids can be?
I have gay friends that took.
They had a kid through a surrogate and
they took their common.
Just mixed it up like a swirly.
I like.
Let's see,
let's see who wins the race.
know they don't really.
They don't really know who won the race.
This cute kid.
He's a great kid,
but they don't know who won that race
guard that they have their guests
guesses.
I read there's a agender baby situation
going on potentially with one of their
bodyguards are still on the mom with the
most recent kid is an obama at the baby
daddy is saying,
you need to get it checked because he's
a famous rapper.
Looks like his bodyguard.
Oh shiT.
I bet those bodyguards get in there.
Of course they do.
They probably ripped.
Yeah,
wasn't there a big thing about kylie?
she has a sexy bodyguard.
Dude.
Looks so you send it.
God damn Bruce Lee movie,
right?
They all have to sleep with the body.
What are you talking about?
You have this guy that's just works out
all the time.
Some bastard.
Kelly.
Jamie's bodyguard.
cryptically responds to baby daddy
rumors.
Okay,
I'm out.
I can't do this anymore.
I can't.
Can't do it anymore.
he's a handsome fellow.
that bodyguard.
I wouldn't blame the gal happened before
though currently.
Hey,
what are you going to do?
Not that I'm.
I don't know.
What are you going to do?
Would just like to remind everybody
we're in space and Hawaii is exploding.
Okay.
If you really give a fuck,
if you really give a fuck which
bodyguard and who's getting the dick
into,
which poor,
confused young lady,
things are gonna happen that way,
man.
Things going to happen.
talking about those body parts.
I was gonna ask if you heard about what
happened to huey lewis recently.
I've been hearing these got some sort of
inner ear infection.
he's got many years and he most
recently,
very recently he was on tour.
I saw people that were like had been to
his concerts,
but he said he can hear people talking
like he was doing an interview with the
woman.
He said,
I can hear your voice,
but I can't hear music.
And like that's what he does is
performed.
It's pretty fucked up man.
Like ears.
Shit is really scary.
My friend,
he's an editor and one day he just woke
up and he can't hear out of his left ear
and he still to this day,
10 years later,
it's still can't hear out of his left.
You didn't happen to me.
I'm pretty sure I have tonight.
It's bad now.
Whoa.
What's tinnitus ringing?
That happens.
I'm used to been a heavy metal band,
so like I never wore earplugs and gone
to tons of concerts for like five plus
years every other night.
Like the cameras down.
That's like.
Yeah.
Yeah,
just to see.
Occasionally just go real high and I
like,
I can't hear anything out of that year
and it's sort of like plug it up or do
something and it'll go away eventually,
but some more recently it's taken a
little longer to go away.
I have that sometimes it's usually when
it's really quiet and I'll just come out
of nowhere.
I hear this like ringing,
but it's not like every day.
Yeah,
that's what it is though.
It's called the.
Yeah.
How do you get it?
It's just an old too.
It's just hearing loss,
hearing loss
be.
You've heard loud things,
you've been the concerts over the years
that damage,
but the real thing I think is people
around guns a lot.
I know a lot of people who are around
guns a lot as a kid,
like they shot those clays with shotguns
and shoot those.
John dudley has real bad hearing loss
from that.
Nobody ever Told kids back then that
they need to wear ear muffs,
like nobody wore ear protection.
They would go to the range with just no
earmuffs on,
bang,
bang concerts.
I don't think I had growing up.
I ever even thought of that.
Like I would sit right next to the
speaker on purpose.
Like I had a nine inch nail concert just
because like,
oh man,
you know,
you're no one talked about that.
in fact,
that's true
nicholas.
Wow,
that's crazy.
You see if you can find video of them in
a gun range with no ear protection
because I don't think I'm making that
up.
I think I remember look watching people
on a range to shooting guns with no
earplugs
nowadays.
It doesn't matter that because their
hearing aids nowadays,
it's like you have earbuds in now and
you get bluetooth to your phone and
everything.
It's cool.
I want to hear hearing aids.
Well,
they have those things called game ears.
You can put them in your hearing in your
ear canal rather like a hearing aid and
they amplify sounds extraordinarily.
And hunters use them in the woods.
They put them in and you can see the
column game is,
I think it's called a walker.
His game here.
I put it on before it freaked me out.
Took it right off.
That's crazy.
I don't even want to hear this.
You're looking for.
Exactly,
but this guy is trying to tell people
how to do it and he was just plugging up
as here.
Oh yeah.
That's not what I'm looking for.
I'm looking for like old school,
so this shoot guns.
If I don't have ear protection,
I just put some articles to people
discussing it,
but nothing's really.
Maybe I imagined it,
but I remember seeing like an old school
range,
some dude with a pistol with like a
thick belt like lowe's.
Hippies used to wearing a belt buckle
and he's firing off that gun.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
I think the first time I shot a gun I
didn't have headphones or ear thing.
Protecting a lot of people.
It's a bad idea.
This does.
Those guys don't know what your
protection.
He gets up and he was lIke,
because he has a concussion.
Catch his breath.
It's so dumb.
Do you know how powerful these things
are?
This is how powerful of 50 calibers
somebody decided.
that's the 30 caliber.
Somebody decided to try to hunt deer
with this.
So there's a video.
You could find it online.
Guy mrs dear,
and the deer's head exploded as it
missed.
The eyes popped out of his head.
He thought it was a perfect headshot
because the deer just went down,
but what it actually was was that the
bullet passing by had so much force it
instantaneously killed the deer.
That crazy.
Dude.
It's insane.
Here it goes.
So this.
So he does this and he's got this big
ass fucking gun.
It says 50 bmg.
I don't know.
What that means is that 50 calibers and
what that means.
So look at this.
He goes over to the,
to the deer and there's no bullet hole.
It's just eyes had blown out of his
fucking head.
Just from the sheer force of that thing
passing by it.
Yeah.
Look,
you could see it like there's a slow
motion of it.
See it passes by.
She doesn't even hit it and the deer
just disappears into the night.
That's nuts.
Like imagine it has so much force.
It can miss a deer and kill it.
Whoa.
That is so unnecessary.
That is such a war weapon.
Fucking.
Amen.
That's a crazy thing to go hunting with.
Who
do you.
Do you use uber a lot like.
no,
you never do.
I don't.
It's too risky.
I'm starting to not trust and it's so
weird.
I use it all the time.
I use delivery,
serve food delivery services all the
time and I'm having second thoughts on
the whole thing.
I think it's great.
I think uber's great.
I'm just fucking around with saying it's
risky.
I mean the idea that you could just call
a cab like,
okay,
how come I can't just call an uber?
The only argument would be that they
don't screen the people as well as the
cab companies.
Exactly.
That's regulated.
Right,
right.
Which is why people like limos though.
They prefer limos,
you know?
I mean,
I was in one recently.
That kid was probably.
He seemed like he was like 17.
like I said,
I had no way this is my dryer and I felt
like he was drunk,
like capital,
how do I get outta here?
You know,
like run a highway right now.
I can't just tell him to pull over on
the side of the highway,
but I feel like he's going to kill me,
you know?
Well,
there was a lady recently that went on
this whole tweet thread.
She,
she tweeted a bunch of different things
to uber about.
A guy was an uber or was it lift one of
those where a guy had taken her under a
bridge and wouldn't,
wouldn't give her her stuff back and
wouldn't let her out of the car and some
passer by stopped and helped her and she
was screaming at the guy and the guy
took off,
but it was to a point where she was
like,
is this guy going to rape me?
Like,
is this guy going to kill me?
is this how I'm going to end?
Like I just jumped in the car with a
stranger and now he's decided to stop
somewhere and it's not.
It's not where we're supposed to go.
He's not telling me why.
That's that kind of shit.
Like I guess that could theoretically
happen with any ride rideshare company,
but with uber it's so weird.
It's just a person just get some person
to come get you and you don't have to be
hired by a company.
Right.
You never thought that with taxis
though.
Like you never thought like,
you know,
you always kind of like taxis were
transportation.
You never thought,
oh this taxi drivers going rate me or
something.
Right.
Well especially in la are the only time
I usually take taxis is in New York.
New york is the place to taxis,
right?
Because it's everywhere.
Yeah.
And that's how people get around.
It's like it's an easy way to get
around,
but you never know.
I mean it's like a ride.
Sometimes those people you'd get in the
car,
like it'd be like,
whoa,
this guy is just ryan and people's asses
and cutting people off.
It's slamming the brakes and honking the
horn.
I whoa.
Like in this dude is tuned in.
He's doing this all day.
He's probably in this fucking car 10,
12 hours a day and so you don't expect
that because you come from
columbus,
Ohio.
we're from columbus.
WasTe.
Still have mormons.
No amish.
The amish.
Do you still have the amish?
Right.
They're hit or miss with electricity
still don't wear deodorant.
Every time I go to New York and I get in
the car and some new yorkers driving
them,
I was like,
whoa,
you guys are in the matrix.
Like they dress drive so much more
aggressively.
Like you know,
if you hire a car to drive you around in
New York city,
they drive so much more aggressively.
They're just so used to it.
I just remember as a kid going to like
wind dot lake and amusement parks.
They always went as a group to amusement
parks.
So there's like 200 amish people mixed
in with us and we'd be like 14,
13 and like look at those guys than the
amish people always acted like so almost
like alien,
like,
like the film the country and they talk
weird and I don't really talk like us
like,
well they stated
to themselves,
right.
I mean,
but I didn't know that they could go to
amusement parks.
I thought there the whole idea was that
they can't use electronics.
That might not have been.
That could have been like a different
group.
There's different kinds of mennonites
too,
right?
yeah.
There's different kinds of.
Quakers.
I was with [inaudible].
We were in Massachusetts,
western Massachusetts.
We,
we stopped into this fucking truck,
stopped to get gas and grabbed something
to eat and there's a group of mennonites
and there's some girl that's wearing
this mennonite outfit and I forget how
ari asked her.
I really wish,
but it was hilarious.
It was something.
Something along the lines of,
so what you in
something along those lines,
it might have been more tactful than
that.
Maybe it was something like,
what's this all about?
Why are you dressed like that?
I think I remember.
I think I was there.
I think you were too.
It was something along the lines of a
group that you're with.
Like it was something to the point where
we were all of course baked out of our
minds.
Yeah.
We're traveling.
We're just trying to be silly.
We just tried to have a good time.
You know,
I think diaz was with too.
It wasn't me.
Yeah.
This poor lady was in this weird cult.
We're in this weird outfit and I think
she answered politely and nice,
like a.
I'm in.
She was like,
yeah.
He's like,
okay.
He's such an unique guy.
Because he was a.
As a child,
he was raised to be a very,
very strict orthodox jew.
You know what I mean?
He spent time,
I forget what it's called when you go
over to Israel and you just read the
torah like fucking 10,
12 hours a day.
He did that,
all that stuff.
He grew the curls.
He had the little strings and hanging
from his belt.
He did all that smiths or something.
What it's called.
It's called orthodox,
right.
That's orthodox judaism.
Yep.
So when anybody tries to run any
bullshit by ra and he's like,
I know this.
He knows all that stuff.
He stabbed the weird curls to and all
that stuff.
He had all that shit.
Yeah.
And then he just realized as he got
older and wiser,
it's like,
oh my god,
this is all bullshit.
Not that it is folks,
this is just,
sorry,
don't take your word for it.
But he's a,
he's a funny guy with that stuff because
like I think only someone who's truly
seen it from the eyes of an absolute
believer.
Imagine that he's gotten through so many
weird looks.
Remember when he just had like a,
like he would always wear the small hats
or something like that.
Like small hats,
memory.
He had the remember he always had like
the hat on that would just hang on the
side of his head.
And he,
I think he had like his head shaped like
a bald.
He definitely shaved his head like a
ball person for awhile.
Did he grow up?
Was that a like a mullet mohawk,
mohawk there?
He's an animal.
He doesn't give a fuck that.
Look.
I like the mohawk look.
Yeah.
The um,
the new thing is the no glasses.
Look,
you've got the lasiks done now.
That's right.
powerful vision.
Now he could see
he got an infected tony had to get it
chopped off.
What?
He lied.
He told me about that he got an
infection on his big toe and he had to
get.
Every move is really good for that.
Is a kurt medsker because kurt metzger
was in.
Was he in the moonies or the christian?
Jehovah's witness.
Jehovah's witnesses.
Yeah.
I think you're right.
Yeah,
so he grew up in the jehovah's witness.
So like he's like,
I'm not buying any of this.
Like I know where this is like why?
Why do people like.
It's the same thing with psychics,
right?
Like why do people have this need to
hold onto irrational beliefs?
Like there are some questions you don't
have answers to.
You know you don't have answers to.
So why don't you pretend that this one,
this,
this answers can take its place.
This answer,
you kind of know bullshit.
It's going to take its place.
Why do we need to do that?
Because so many of us do,
and I'm not immune to it.
We're all,
we all need that feeling.
You know the to know still.
It's going to be okay,
brian,
how everything's gonna be.
Okay.
It makes me wonder if you did the whole
gun theory,
if this is real or not to religion,
how many people would say yes,
it's all real and who would go?
Even the most religious person would
like.
No,
of course not.
We on it.
I like,
it helps me out.
Um,
I think a bunch of people would take a
bullet.
If you want to punish me for my lord
heaven,
they'd take it right in the temple.
Boom.
Piles of people.
Piles of bodies at walmart.
Yeah,
man.
People would just blow their brains out
for their heavenly father does command
you to come see him in heaven.
Boom.
Yeah.
Lot of people would do it.
Guaranteed.
But you know,
man,
it's like even what's going on with the
pope just recently said,
there's no hell.
Everybody went crazy.
Like,
what?
What did he just sang?
The pope said,
there's no hell he's,
he's slowly bracing you for the fact
that all this is nonsense,
but right now we're going to get rid of
hell.
Like this is like one of the,
one of the purest examples of like the
change in people's attitudes towards
religious real.
Yup.
The vatican denies that.
But yeah,
the vatican did not say there is no hell
we'll find out an article where it says
he did say that 50 percent shit.
He's not going to cut it back.
Go back in time and find an article
where he did say,
I guarantee you.
He did say,
let's just assume at one day the.
See this is what they do.
They say it a little bit and then they
take it back.
So they get used to the idea that
they're saying it.
That's what it is.
I'm full eddie bravo right now for
conspiracy.
Dude.
This is how they set it up.
They start out with uh,
uh,
they tell you the hell's not real.
Then they say,
we never said that.
And then a year from now they say,
look,
we're pretty sure hell is not real.
This pope probably plays fortnight and
shit.
He's like,
he's cool pope.
He doesn't have the pope immobile.
Scott is.
Kanye is on.
He's a cool pope.
He is the cool pope.
He got rid of the throne.
Okay.
Yeah.
He had a big giant crazy ass thrown for
the last guy.
The creeper.
He's got a gamer chair down those racing
chairs.
The headphoneS where I just got one of
those.
pope francis in the fucking house.
Pope francis has no problem with gay
people either.
See pope francis fighting with your or
kid.
Yeah.
see,
look how he swapped.
You look at the old,
the old thrown versus the new throne.
Look at the two side to side.
The guy on the left guy,
they just kicked out for crimes against
humanity and the guy on the
right is the new guy who's just got a
sensible chair much better.
The other throne is creepy man.
That is crazy.
And he dresses much more conservatively
two.
He's not wearing crazy wizard robes.
He's wearing like a one color wizard
robe
dresses like r kelly on a sunday.
Just crazy.
Like if he came out and like a polo
shirt and pair of jeans.
No.
Right?
Everybody like,
hey,
you can't be the paul.
Put out the fucking magic outfit.
Where's your fish head hat?
Come on,
bro.
He's got body armor on.
He's got a hat on
golden salmon that's coming out of the
top of his head.
Like,
show me that hat.
This fucking hat.
Sad is preposterous.
That's a.
That's like a monster.
That's a mouth.
After I got like a,
like a giant snake.
It looks like a napkin at a restaurant.
When you go there and it's sitting in.
Oh well it's nicely done.
Little rings.
Probably put it on by mistake like he's
just going look at me.
I can't believe they're making fun of
our holy father on this.
Fucking show sucks.
You'll make fun of our holy father.
He's right there with the smoke.
Oh my god.
How is this still legal?
Look at these kids dressed up like
they're in harry potter's seminary and
build the life that they look good.
They do.
They look like they're go to that.
What's that hogwarts school?
They do.
This is fucking ridiculous.
Universal talking to this dude who's
holding up a golden version of where the
savior was murdered,
right?
He's got a golden cross.
This crosses all over the place like
don't forget about the cross
and he standing there dressed like a
wizard.
This is craziness.
And everybody's.
No,
no,
no.
This is our reLigion.
This is our culture.
This is weird.
This is weird and I'm not saying it's
not beautiful.
It's absolutely beautiful.
I'm not saying it's any weirder than
going to the opera because I think
that's weird too,
but this shit is weird.
This is some really old form of
education slash entertainment that
people used to do before they had plays.
They get together and some room.
What's fucking crazy?
Different colored glass windows in it.
Doesn't have a mic on.
Why did that kid got to hold the mic?
Because jesus doesn't want him to be an
magnified.
That's a thick mic though.
Yeah.
Manager was pink.
She had a pink mike.
What's it?
What's it buys?
It have to be silver.
I like pink,
pink.
Pink mic.
It's a.
It's crazy.
You know,
and it's a billion of us and I was
raised there.
I mean I was from when I was real little
kid.
I did at least one year in catholic
school was around a lot of catholics,
you know,
and I'm not claiming to be an expert in
it,
but I don't have to be that shit's
bananas.
I used to be an altar server.
I used still hold that mic.
Did you really?
Did you.
Were you ever in the middle of doing
that?
Going what in the fuck am I doing?
Not the.
Most of the times
we did it and me and my friends talk
about we would get out of class so we
would,
because I went to catholic school,
there'd be services during the day and
funerals even sometimes we get paid to
be out of class and then we would like
miss two,
three hours of school was getting paid
20 bucks,
get some donuts,
miss lunch.
Know that was really all we were doing.
I used to just have to light the candles
like I me and this other kid would come
out and lay all these candles.
I always wanted to be the guy that puts
them out with that bell on the hook.
So bananas when you're in that room and
they'll see those benches all laid out
up to the pulpit like this is so crazy,
this is.
It's like people figured out some way to
make the bridge between physical
evolution and mental evolution.
Like there's this bridge between us not
being monkeys anymore,
but still we just want to get out of the
barbarian behavior.
We've got to figure out a way to get
people to like have reverence for
something is all powerful and just
control their behavior.
We've got to slow down the chimp in a
santa monkey like that.
That's what it looks like.
A monkey.
The monkey statue.
The feast of the chair of st peter and
address.
What is the statue?
It's just a bronze statue of st peter.
I said this is a dark statue.
Try to tell you.
St peter was black
truth.
There's a.
it's weird.
When we were in charlottesville,
the they had the black israelites there
that were right out in front of the
building that they used to set up shop
all the time in New York to run into
those dudes.
Just wander down the street.
I was told that because I'm italian,
I'm not white.
I said,
oh yeah.
He told me that.
I was like,
thank you.
I know you are.
I did see that.
I did see that,
but yet I'm certainly not black,
so keep going.
According to these black israelites,
I am not white,
so I'm okay.
The true nation,
is that them?
I love how they dress like mean.
they take that whole pope shit to the
next level.
They're like,
fuck,
that man won't be like he mad master of
the universe,
the dress and it's crazy.
Look at how they're dressing.
They have shields and shit,
bro.
Go to that.
Make that picture bigger.
Please make that picture bigger.
These are serious people there on the
street.
They're reading from the bible.
One guy has a sword.
Okay,
this guy's got an ax.
the other guys got to pick acts like
he's going to go find gold.
This is one of the craziest pictures of
this is real.
Is that real champion barrier?
That's.
Go back to that please.
Jamie,
go back to that police for a second.
What did it say?
There was something in the.
The text that went with it.
So that it.
Yeah,
there it is.
What does it say?
Passover?
Twelve.
I sup k passover from wikipedia.
So
it looks like a mixed tape.
What is the high holy day?
Passover in harlem,
New York.
20 12.
Oh my god.
So that's the black israelites at the
high holy day.
Passover.
Black israelites who think there are
different kinds of jus the dea so called
jews that looks like fun.
I'll do that.
Doesn't look like fun until someone gets
drunk.
Start swinging an ax around.
What do they got there?
They're teaching white people stuff.
They got these posters.
Six,
six,
six.
Preach on brother.
Okay.
The dress cool though.
Look at that outfit.
All leather.
giant star.
David duke has a sword.
No big deal.
Just two dudes walking around with a
stored.
They're going to fucking like.
It looks like a holiday inn or
something.
Right?
It doesn't look like some sort of
banquet center.
When they have the sword show the
picture of the sword.
Where are they?
Where the fuck is that going on?
That seems like a very public place.
That was sort,
sir.
What's that place you eat at and then
they all looked like that.
Their horse chow,
evil man type places.
Middle east.
The times.
Maybe two times.
Yeah.
I believe medieval manner was a place
like that in boston.
I think there's a few of those all over
the.
I never went to one of those either die.
I'm just scared of the people that go to
those things.
Oh yeah,
there is not.
They were closed.
I don't want to go to it.
Well,
isn't that renaissance fair thing going
on right now?
Yeah,
that's.
I'd rather get that.
That.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
it's kinda cool.
I used to collect copper soldiers from.
It's something fun.
It's interesting.
It was funny because one lady broke
character,
um,
and she was complaining about her
husband's medication and the other lady
said,
I do not understand this medication that
you speak of.
She stayed in her like,
she was like,
bitch,
we're here making believe.
I don't want to hear about.
Your husband complained about his pills.
Well,
they've got them on this one thing and I
don't know what that's for,
but then this other thing is supposed to
counteract this medication.
It's like,
mA'am,
I do not understand if this medication
or speak up for him just to winch.
And I await the prince.
Bizarre.
Like you're not supposed to break
character.
Yeah.
And these people like really get into it
and then I bet they get drunk and fuck
each other.
Don't you think?
I'm sure this must be a god damn crazy
person's orgy.
They all get together with their wacky
outfits on phone each other and fake
accents.
My neighbors,
when they fence in the backyard,
why not?
They look hot to go for a kid's jam.
pretty people.
Why not?
Right?
Why not put on a fucking
like a pirate's outfit?
Like why not?
Have you ever seen those pirate themed
bars where they all have to dress up as
pirates?
Right.
and,
and when they get off work,
they still think they're pirates.
Like there's a whole show about africa,
what the show is called.
So like they get locked into that.
Yeah,
they get,
they stay,
they stay in character.
oh jesus christ.
Like what about when they go home,
they're watching tv,
they're pirates sitting home watching
frasier.
So like when they talked to their google
home thing and they're like,
hey,
google add,
let me know where the ale is cold and
the women are hot.
Do You have a lot of home like siri and
alexa was at your house?
I don't trust those.
That asshole thing or is that asshole
that you can make a series say uh oh
motherfucker.
Motherfucker.
Yeah,
you can make siri say motherfucker.
Yeah.
People think I was joking about that.
Let me show you how to do that.
Watch this folks.
Here we go.
What is the definition
that taco bell?
So that's good.
What's the definition of mother?
Come on you piece of shit.
There's no need for that.
Oh,
I'm sorry about that.
what's the definition of mother
as a noun?
it means a woman in relation to the
child or children to them.
She has given birth.
Do you want to hear the next one?
Yes.
As a verb.
It means bringing up a child with care.
And affection.
Do you want to hear the last one?
yes.
As a verb.
It means give birth to.
Oh my god.
Siri bitch.
Chicken from.
Yeah,
they,
they removed it.
But you know what?
come on.
It was funny.
How did they leave it in there and then
take it out?
Do they take out the dead body one that
remember the first one?
That's a crazy one.
Short for motherfucker.
Yeah,
it would say as a,
you know?
Yeah,
I bet.
Just the still has it.
I think I tweeted what it said.
What exactly it said.
Yeah,
I,
I did it.
I did it the day you did it and it took
me a couple tries because I didn't say
it right.
But it ended up doing.
It
did it says as a noun.
Short form motherfucker.
But it could be a verb as well,
right?
yeah.
If you're actually a motherfucker
sierra with mother means and it gives
you the correct definition,
then it asks you.
Do you want to hear the next one?
If you said yes,
it says as a noun,
it means short from motherfucker.
Yeah,
I got it right.
But it was weird to hear like I heard it
and I was like,
what?
That's real.
Like imagine if that's like your mom and
she's teaching a little kid how to use
siri.
Like,
mommy,
how do I know what mommy is?
Well,
we can ask siri,
sweetie.
We can ask siri what mother means.
A let's do it.
Do you want to hear the next one?
Okay.
As a noun.
short for motherfucker.
the little kids.
Like what would that mean?
What did they say?
What does serious say?
If you ask santa is real or some shit
like that.
Oh,
is santa real?
I'm going to pretend you didn't ask
that.
I don't want you to get a lump of coal
this year.
Alexa tells you and uses the shares a
needle.
Siri,
are you allowed to swear?
I don't have the answer to that.
Is there something else I can help you
with?
I just want to know if you stopped using
curse words recently.
I'm not sure I understand.
Well,
earlier in this week I had asked you
what mother means and you gave me one
definition then you had.
You said,
do you want to hear the next one and you
said as a noun it means short for
motherfucker.
I just thought that was weird.
Not nice.
Siri,
you sound like a crazy person.
I'm trying to talk to you about this
issue that you and I are having about
communication and what do you say to me?
You say that's not nice.
What's not nice for you to say,
motherfucker in front of that little
three year old just learning how to
talk.
Wow,
this is the future.
Here's some of the stuff I was telling
you about.
This is the future we're going to be
having arguments with our digital
devices like that.
Like that's a crude like helper.
I get super crude helper,
right?
Like what siri could do and not do.
It's very crude,
but this is just like the iphone one,
right?
Maybe they're going to have them.
They're absolutely going to have some
sort of ai that can keep up with the
conversation for sure.
That's going to happen.
It's.
It's pretty crazy how much ahead.
I think google and alexa are ahead of
siri,
like there's terrible.
Yeah.
I mean,
having both of the home pod on the siri
and alexa echo or whatever.
It's night and day difference.
What's better?
Siri or bixby?
Bixby is a samsung one.
Uh,
I think uh,
well big speeds,
very new.
I think series better than that.
But like alexa,
they've,
they've even improved alexis so much.
Were you seeing like,
hey alexa,
sing me a love song and there's a whole
song that alexa sings deal and there's
like 10 of these songs.
Well,
I think that google has it down the best
with the google pixel two phone.
When you squeeze the sides and the
google assistant comes on and when the
google assistant comes on and you just
ask it anything and google assistant is
just better.
Google is good.
It just,
it just works better.
it's better if it finds your results
better.
It As clunky.
It doesn't seem as weird,
you know,
I think we're in this weird right now
with phones,
you know,
it's like we're expecting things of
phones thAt we don't even want or need
and they've never asked for before.
What we're looking for,
augmented reality phoneS,
a double is projectors to project a
fucking movie on a wall.
I've seen those.
They have phones.
Do not know.
It's.
It's very interesting.
I love paying with my phone.
That's my knuth who said great love
apple.
Pay your face.
Use your face.
Should he pay for shit or apple watch.
You don't have to do shit.
What did you think?
I didn't talk to you about this.
What did you think about the us
government telling us not to use walway
phones.
A huawei phones are made by the chinese
and they're like,
don't trust the way phones.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean there might be something to it.
Like if it's a something that say,
you know,
like an iphone,
it sends messages to apple all the time.
I've location and,
and all that crap like that.
So that's like a foreign country that
has the ability to track it's people,
you know,
it's,
it's a little weird.
I,
I see why they did it,
but it's a shape found anyway.
Who cares?
Well
apparently they're in some sort of a
dispute with huawei about Iran.
See if we can find that like something
way to be punished.
Something I ran something about servers
that they sold to Iran.
They're not supposed to sell.
I don't know,
jamie will find the article,
but then they were saying we recommend
you not using that.
Consumers not use their phones.
And a bunch of tech guys that I was
reading,
I was reading a bunch of articles and
the tech guys were super skeptical
because one of the things they were
saying,
it's like with anything is in there,
we'll find it like you,
you can't just say like,
they might be using these things as spy
devices without any,
without any evidence.
It says while ways under us criminal
investigation for illegal Iran sales
heels.
Here's what's next.
So the other,
the other,
um,
theory by the super conspiracy theorists
is that they're trying to keep out the
number three,
um,
cell phone maker in the world from
establishing a foothold in the us mArket
and economically strengthening the
communist government over there or
pseudo communist government.
what are they?
Now?
They're communists,
but they,
you can make money.
When I,
I literally saw sometimes stumbled
across something.
I think on instagram yesterday,
there's just a post about walway and
them being linked to the ccp,
which is the communist party in China.
People are like,
don't do it.
It's too bad dude,
because they got this fucking phone.
Electro megapixels on the camera.
Right?
That's what you didn't bitch.
Don't shoot down my dreams.
I don't piss on your yeezys need to
check him on these.
Huawei is,
took a day off of the easiest.
Weiwei has as
this um,
um,
something mate pro porsche design rs,
something rs.
It's a crazy phone.
It's got 500 gigabytes of storage.
Five hundred,
500 gigabytes of storage.
It's crazy.
I think maybe even more than 500.
It's got a 40 megapixel camera.
It turns,
literally turns night into day.
When you take photos,
like when they have a list,
like a four second aperture will stay
open and you see the pictures and you're
like,
holy shit.
You see regular camera photos.
And then they see the photos with his
camera.
They're like,
hands down.
This is the best camera in cell phones
today.
Do you know how hard it would be to take
that picture though?
Oh yeah.
Super hard.
Deadly for four seconds or the.
It'd be all blurry and fucked up.
Um,
I don't know how that works.
You do more than I do.
You would have to really hold it steady.
Right?
Like,
like sit it on something ready.
Couldn't even track my button.
You'd have to have a remote trigger.
You'd fuck it up by even maybe touching
it and then it'll give you a slight
pause and then they'll start.
They don't probably.
They might do that now actually,
but they don't typically do that.
See if you can go to that.
It's camera.
Go to the walway.
What is the.
I think it's like the mate 10 art.
Is that it?
Yeah.
Do this phone as this shit.
I'm disgusted that it's a spy device
because I want one so bad.
So I think.
Isn't that good?
I mean,
have you looked at the reviews?
Are we terrible?
Their reviews?
Probably like,
yeah,
it's not as good as an iphone if I want
it to be honest with you.
I liked the fact that there's
competition.
It makes me excited.
You just like the porsche wall felt like
that too.
Sure.
Obviously.
I like those cars.
I liked their engineering.
They,
they,
they're german wizards.
They know how to design shit and a
really spectacular way.
They make cool stuff.
They make cool watches and shit,
but I think what's really.
Well,
there's a bunch of things interesting to
me about it,
but what's interesting to me is when
these cameras and these phones from
these android manufacturers are so good,
it forces apple to come with some next
level shit too.
Like this is a technology race,
unlike any other race,
like computers have even stalled out.
Right?
Like you get a new mac book.
Do you even pay attention to what the
fucking gigabytes are now?
Now you know,
you remember the gigahertz were like the
thing like you want to log a two point
seven.
Should I pay more for the three point
two?
Remember that?
Yeah.
$300.
$500 more for one point.
Yeah.
Remember they take those celeron and
overclocking.
You know,
people will do anything to get to one,
you know,
one,
100 megahertz or what?
What's,
what's like three gigahertz is like a
good laptop,
right?
It's all about quad core processors now.
Right now it's course.
But in the old days like you'd get like
a celeron 400 right multithreading
thread.
Like when they hit one gigahertz,
people were shitting their pants.
Like I can't believe we got a one
gigahertz computer.
This is madness.
Overclocking still,
I don't think it pushes above five,
maybe
number overclocking due to go into the
little spacers were those things called
again,
jumpers,
the jumpers and move them around and
change things in the bios.
Your fuckIng computer be catching on
fire and be running so hot.
Yeah,
that shit's real.
I used to work at gateway.
That was always so fun because we always
had the brand new computers.
Like tHe day it came out like,
oh,
we had the new pentium two,
you know,
and it was fun playing with computers
that fast.
Yeah man.
Cella ron's.
So I just got from my twitch channel
selling computer.
No.
Oh,
bad ass over clock to sli video cards
and the shit called m dot two storage,
which is super fast and it's crazy.
Well now what is this?
What company is this from?
Uh,
the company that made it is a origin pc.
They put together the parts that gave me
a pretty cool glass with my logo on it
and all that kinda shit.
There's led lights in it.
Someone was looking at waste some time.
I got a razor laptop.
Yeah,
that razor,
her laptop is like one of the closest
things.
So like,
like build quality,
the way a mac book fields with the metal
frame and still tight tolerances and it
could keyboard and shit.
Yeah,
it's a great computer.
It's powerful.
I mean I use it for virtual reality and
it's scott,
one of the best graphics cards you can
buy and it's,
it's pretty sweet.
I used to
by everything apple.
I used to just buy apple laptops,
apple phones.
But I like it that it's a question now,
you know,
like I told you that I started using
that thinkpad.
I liked the thing way better than a mac
book.
The keyboard is way more responsive.
There's.
There's travel to the keys,
like it's easier to type like there's
something about those little clickety
click keys that the new mac books have.
Were you the you make more mistakes?
They don't.
You don't have a feel to them because
you're not,
you know,
like,
oh yeah,
that clicked.
Oh yeah.
That clicked through a clumsy type or
like me,
I type way better on a keyboard that has
some travel to it.
Like you get some feel,
you get a feel of what you're doing and
where the letters are.
The new macbook pro is probably one of
the worst versions of any mac book pro
since they started making it.
I hate the new mac book pro with a
passion in that.
The the dongle shit needs to stop.
Like the other day I needed a usb port.
I didn't.
Hey,
I forgot my dongle.
There was no way for me to do it.
Anything that I needed to do.
It's the worst.
It's the worst us hudson's just not
where yet.
You know wHat I mean?
It's a lot of things you could charge
your phone with usbc with.
There's some things that you have their
old usb and if you have to be like,
oh
well this is useless.
I wish apple would have a exchange
program where you could go in and
they'll take out your touch bar and that
keyboard and just put in like any
keyboard you want.
Like I just want to regular mac book,
pro keyboard on my laptop
in the mac book,
but the thing about this thinkpad jammy,
the way the keys work,
like when you're typing on it,
there's all this travel.
THey feel good.
Like I can,
like I put my finger onj and f and when
I'm typing I can.
They feel like they're pressing the
press,
press.
It's not like a,
like no.
Travel doesn't give you the same amount
of feedback any guy ports,
but feel a lightness.
That's the crazy thing.
That's nice.
Yeah.
I like that little light.
Sexy,
really sexy,
great battery life too.
What do you know what this processor is?
Do you know what a.
It's a seller on 400.
Dude,
don't don't quick on this bro.
So we're going to set up a land party
here where we're trying to figure out
the right way to do it,
but we're going to set up a land party
here.
GAme now a fortnight.
Is that.
Oh,
you guys are doing.
I think he will be addicted to fortnight
in underground more than anyone.
You know,
if you have a limited amount of time,
we go right back to quake.
What happens?
Yeah,
but it's like the.
If you like quake,
you'll love this.
Champions game was this quick online
game.
Looks so crazy good.
And the fact that it's all web based
now.
Come on son.
It's.
Yeah,
went away some time.
Come on over man.
Folks and people up.
Bring some people into a room.
You would be a championship gamer,
wouldn't if you.
If you got into it and if you got into
it,
you would be like one of the top gamer.
You'd be the ninja.
No,
no.
I'm a not quite artistic enough
to get the top of the food chain.
Fat ass.
I don't know who he is.
You see the top guy when you say is the
top guy,
he's one of my favorItes to watch.
He got drake on.
I think honestly that video games are
pro at high level,
especially quake.
It's deceptively intellectually
challenging.
Like when they have these,
um,
they would do a lot of these,
one on one death matches and they would
be in a room and they would both spawn
at the same time.
Then you have to run,
you have to have knowledge of the map
and you also have to have knowledge of
when certain items are going to respond.
Like if you steal the rocket launcher,
the,
another rocket launcher will respond and
like I forget how many seconds,
like 30 seconds.
So they would run the map,
shoot the guy,
collect the extra rocket launch before
he can to keep him unarmed and keep
killing them over and over again.
And after you kill them a certain amount
of time,
the game is over.
And tHe guys who are really good at
that,
we're just,
they're just really smart.
They're really smart,
really fast.
Twitch,
super tuned into the game,
just like locked in.
And then they studied those maps and
then they also study like movement.
They could do crazy shit like rocket
jump onto people and do things like
that,
like get to areas of the map just
because they understood how to hop.
They could do it in a way that other
people don't know how to do that.
The guy ninja he's talking about is what
you're describing.
So then again,
fortnight you have to build these crazy.
Is this fortnight?
Yeah,
you have to be,
you find mats which are materials and
you billed for it.
So it becomes,
these are one on one matches.
If you're playing solo where you have to
like literally build advantage.
You have to gain advantage.
Why is that?
Why other bricks flying in the air?
He's gaining the materials.
So you're mining.
Oh.
And then that becomes what you're
talking about.
You have to like either you have only a
couple guns you can choose from.
So how did this build this bridge here?
So he's doing it that fast and he's.
He knows there's a guy over there and
he's going to attack right now.
Oh wow.
And it's his decision on how he does it
though and the map never changes really.
They just sort of changed through the
building to get in there.
You can build it back up.
I got a problem with this game because
to addictive,
addictive,
just watching the addictions,
the colors to this game has gotten some
crazy colors which is like crack for
your brain.
This is amazing.
And it's weird because grown adults just
Fallen in love with this overnight.
Well that's what I'm saying.
Like I was joking around about video
games
that I'm not artistic enough.
I think the best guYs are going to be
considered like chess players.
I think it's like kind of the same
thing.
It's just chest is traditionally
worshiped as this intellectual game.
Right.
But I think that a lot of video games
like starcraft for sure is like this
really high level strategy game.
Like you're doing things and you're
thinking on multiple levels about
different parts of the board and
different things that you're moving
around.
It seems to me to be like physically
dynamic too because things are moving
quick like you,
you're not,
you're not in control of what your
opponent is doing while he's doing it.
It's all happening in one time.
You try to think your way through things
and put stuff here and move stuff there
too.
This were,
we under appreciate them because when
they first started out they were
frivolous like pong and stuff like that
to,
to uh,
to it.
So we think of them as being dumb,
but they're so sophisticated now and
kids were making fucking shitloads of
money to who was,
who was saying that
he was saying that your kid,
like you should parents should probably
encourage their kids to play games
because there's fucking money in it.
Now.
You know,
johnny caRson's old studio,
you've been there probably a million
times.
Jay leno studio,
it's now a blizzard arena right down the
street from me.
He's like,
there's everyday they had to go there.
If you want to go check it out,
I would love to go to right down the
street from me.
That's crazy.
But it's a every time I drive by,
it's just crowds of people like a sports
game.
Okay.
Now I want you to put on quake
champions.
Goodness gracious.
What do you mean?
So
what is this?
The game is called overwatch.
I'm trying to find that an arena.
Uh,
things too.
You can see what it looks like.
Just put it on quick.
I don't want to see any more of this
shit.
Fucks.
Good.
Quick arena quake championships,
whatever they call it.
Even on the,
on the side it says something about
quake and joe rogan.
Work it out on quick.
Watch this.
Here we go,
son.
What does this.
Is that an ad first?
Whoa
gameplay.
Dude.
Come on.
See,
this is way better.
Look at this.
This is old school.
This room.
I want to play it because it reminds me
of the old.
I mean,
look at the graphics in this fucking
thing.
God damn graphics are good now.
I mean it's just.
I wonder if tHat's bad for your eyes or
good for your eyes.
imagine if they found out that video
games actually improve eyesight.
Remember when we grew up,
they were told us not to sit next close
to the tv,
but now we are sold vr units where we're
the closest to a tv possibly made.
What happened to that?
Look at this motherfucker.
Dude.
This game looks perfect.
This unreal.
This is still quake britain endless.
Dun dun dun.
She that rocket jump.
Yep.
Come on son.
what was the one?
Was a quake the one that they had the
space one where you just like trampoline
to over?
Yes.
Yeah.
I think that was quick.
Two,
it had that they did that.
They had bouncy little things
everywhere.
I came along at quick to um,
I didn't play a whole lot of quake one,
but quake one was really fun.
I played a little bit of it.
It was really fun.
Quake one was um,
these like kind of blocky looking dudes
with helmets on.
They run around shooting each other,
but it was like real fast paced,
like unrealistically fast paced.
Like it wasn't like this.
One of the things that some people like
about,
uh,
what was that half life game that people
would play was based off a half life and
it was like an army game.
Like counterstrike.
Yeah.
Most popular game probably still right
now.
Yeah.
People love that.
Love that game.
One of the things they loved about it
was that it had more realistic
physics
ticket.
How many times did your phone rings?
You take a picture of the screen.
How many times,
if you,
how many of your photos or screenshots?
Unnecessary screenshots over a mountain?
Yeah.
Um,
what wIll we,
what was I just saying?
Oh,
halflife turned into army.
Yeah.
So if you go to quake one,
what is this game you counterstrike?
Oh,
this is the graphics.
It's honestly,
I'm pretty sure it's still the same
levels as back in whatever night.
They just have one item hd,
which is better.
This looks incredibly.
This looks good.
We gotta get you guys' computers.
Got headshot it dead.
Wake up with a knife.
Trying to find a gun.
Here we go.
Okay.
Go to quake one.
What's that?
I'm just on twitter.
Oh,
this is a guy playing on twitch.
Oh wow.
Summit playing live.
They have a quake one game live now.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
that's crazy.
To see anything.
If you're curious about a new game,
you just go to twitch and watch someone
playing.
It's like
a dude waiting for someone to play him.
I like to go to sleep watching a girl
play some boring ass game.
Like there's people out there.
They're still into this.
This is how crazy quake one was.
The graphics didn't even matter because
the game,
it was all dark and moody and the
gameplay was so fun that a lot of people
even stayed with it after quake two and
then quake three became like sort of
fast paced like that.
See if you can find a video of people
playing it.
here's a comparison of the old one
versus the other.
Updated graphics.
This.
Yeah,
it was super blocky.
What was the game that.
There was a mod.
it was a mild,
but you're in the bathroom,
like in here hiding and toilets and on
toilet paper rolls.
I feel like I've already asked this,
but yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I know talking about those,
I think those rocket arena,
there was like a rocket to read a map
where you could play quake and the
bathroom was my favorite.
I've spent days on that.
Well,
there was a bunch of maps that people
would create,
you know,
and there was even map making software
and you could,
you could make a bap and guys were
always doing it.
It was,
it was a really common thing.
There was a joe rogan level.
Remember somebody made that.
Oh,
with the jre?
Yeah.
Look a little logo.
I think so.
I think someone did do something like
that.
I remember that,
but it's a.
I remember they would do all these new
maps would come out and we would play
matches on these new maps.
You'd kick my ass till five in the
morning,
dude.
you're like,
no,
don't get off yet.
I had a real problem.
The real problem with games,
you know,
doing my best,
doing my best to avoid them,
but we're going to indulge a little bit
here.
Virtual reality,
man,
that's my.
That's my favorite man.
I can't get an I love it.
And now you could play like,
was it doom or first person shooter?
I forget which one it assumes on there
and follow up for us on that.
Yeah.
You play doom.
Doom in vr.
Can you show me that?
Show me doom in vr.
Which doom is it?
Is it the more recent tickets?
The original.
The original design?
It probably.
I think so,
but it's probably like the cpu power
probably isn't able to keep up.
I want to upgrade my age.
This is not the original one.
It's an upgraded version of it.
Oh,
is it?
just upgraded graphics of this.
Um,
this does not look like this.
Looks like the newer ones took the
original doom and remade it remastered
if you will,
is what it's called.
That's crazy.
I actually bought this.
So this is doom vfr,
which is a special vr version and I
think they might've have some levels.
I don't know if it's the actual full
game from start to finish.
oh my god dude.
But when you said it's the original
game,
I thought you meant like with the
original graphics,
these graphics are really good.
This is,
this will fuck your life up.
I said I could've brought it.
We should do this,
this right here to fuck your life up.
This looks way too fun.
You don't have virtual reality.
You have virtual reality at your house.
No.
Oh,
you got to get her to go running.
I work out.
Do things.
Oh,
we don't want them to do that anymore,
man.
That scared the shit out of me.
That legitimately scared the shit out of
me that watching that video,
the doom because was like,
that could ruin my life.
Did the features liposuction as kanye
man,
liposuction opioids and playing virtual
reality to them until it shrivel up.
I'm trying to make 1:30.
That's how you do it.
Just just play video games all day.
You never eat.
Stay quito.
What games do you play in a.
I just got a god of war.
The new god of war,
which that looks.
You want to see graphics.
That's amazing graphics.
So to me,
I saw one in the commercial,
but it looks incredible.
Yeah,
it's that and that's a real fun game.
I tried to get into far cry five,
but I like the color aspect.
Like at first I,
I,
I told duncan trussell you have to buy
this immediately because there was,
is this is a real walk through gameplay.
Gameplay.
Yeah.
Loading screen.
There's no game to look at them.
The steam coming out of his mouth.
This is incredible.
Yeah,
and no,
like you said,
no loads screens.
It goes in like,
that's just the game dude.
This is nuts.
Yeah.
That's the third person.
Or do you do it?
First person.
Keep this going,
jamie,
to show you some cool shit on it.
Jamie's real cliquey today.
Notice quickly is that adderall is going
crazy.
Going crazy.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
This is nuts.
Yeah.
Do that again.
Well,
not all the way.
All the way to the beginning.
I want to see like how they set it up
to help him out.
I'm actually shooting it.
Are good.
Do playing this shooting in the head.
He's trying to.
Why would you do that?
Because you know.
Go.
There you go.
Good,
good.
Thanks.
Tait fletcher.
This is real.
This is real clunky.
Looking like it doesn't look real,
but it looks way realer than anything
I've ever seen before.
So this is check this out.
This is actually like,
this is.
You're battling some of you guys trying
to kill you with that big rock.
Yeah,
it's a.
Games are amazing now.
shadows and everything.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
Well what I'm saying is that like,
I mean this obviously looks amazing,
but in how many years do you think it
will be indistinguishable from real
life?
10,
20,
20 for short,
right?
In 20 years you don't think so.
Sort of skeptical on this a little bit
because I feel like the bar keeps
getting moved at five years,
10 years.
Every couple of years.
We get,
we get close skeptic over here.
We get close but it's still like the
window,
the window.
You get your first five.
It was,
it's been four or five years I've had or
the oculus rift since beta testing,
so I've had always had it and I just had
a big vr la thing this weekend and I
didn't hear anyone sharing anything that
was like mind blowing experiences that
are making everyone go out and spend
$2,000 on a vr rig.
Well,
I Think right now what's happening is
the infancy of vr in a commercial level.
That's what we're seeing.
I mean,
it's like if you go back to the early
day at targhee boxes and then compare
them to a new xbox.
I mean,
I think that's where we're looking at.
You're just saying that it's not
happening quick.
Those definitely happens.
Those are gigantic gaps,
but you can look at it from a different
perspective and be like,
it's still just playing with the remote
control on a tv with some computer power
behind it.
And even those virtual stuff is also
sometimes connected to those three
dimensional.
Um,
uh,
one of those things that,
how do they call them?
They don't call the treadmill,
what do they call them?
new track omnisphere.
Yeah.
That thing,
have you seen that thing?
Yeah,
you're strapped into the center of this
thing and it moves.
The rest of you could walk through these
three d environments,
but you know if you.
But if I was gonna save just 20 years
ago,
what kind of bullshit ass graphics were
we looking at and now look at what we're
looking at now.
They just 20 years from now they'll
probably have it like at the very least
it'd be like watching marijuana or
something.
That's what I just still feel like it
was still feel super fake,
will still know that this is still a big
world and it's not going to ever get
lost in it pretty.
I think it's easy to get lost in it
nowadays.
They have big rooms almost like size of
chuck cheese where you renting out in so
you don't need a treadmill because
you're actually going through obstacles
that are feel real.
Like they would if they did it in a way
where it's like it's,
it's,
it's not realistic,
but it's really good.
Like,
like what if they did despicable me?
Like you were in despicable me.
You know the animated movie with the.
What's the dude's name,
the fucking bad guy.
I know you're damaged.
Yes.
I forget.
Is the bad guy in the character's name?
That was a group except like that.
Is that his name?
Honestly,
I don't have any candy.
I have kids,
but the graphics are incredible.
It's beautiful.
I mean it's stunning to look at it like,
wow,
they did an amazing job with this,
but it's obviously not real.
You know what I'm saying?
You wanted to be like,
like that or like extra,
not just a simulation of your life.
You'd want to be able to fly early,
you know,
jump over fucking buildings.
You've gone.
You've done the simpsons game right in
universal fucking incredible.
Right.
So good to ride the ride.
Yeah.
Well the.
So again,
that ride where it's this huge video
screen and your,
your car moves up and down and they're
just taking you through this crazy thing
that you're seeing in front of you and
it's probably as thrilling as any actual
ride where you're really moving.
Right.
Is the back of the future ride though?
Before that?
I didn't see that one because then 40
yet the 40 theaters out here.
no,
that's what you try,
Man.
That's where you're.
The whole thing moves with the movie and
there's also smell.
There's also missed and potter.
Yeah,
it's.
It looked like ivan pukey kind of.
Is it like that?
Star wars ride star tours at disneyland.
You ever done that?
Yeah.
It's kind of like that.
Yeah,
the moves and you could turn off like,
I don't want water.
I don't want to fart.
There will be something like that.
I feel like I was trying to look it up
right now,
but I remember steven spielberg talking
about developing a room type theater
process process.
We're.
You're not.
Maybe you're not wearing anything,
but things are being projected into the
room you're in and you're experiencing
the movie like that.
Like maybe like avatar in the future
would be like 25 people jump into the
room and it starts playing and you're
just experiencing it happen around you
versus wearing a headset and watching
something happen.
I don't think they've developed it yet,
but I have seen some beautiful in
holograms,
man.
Some big globe globes is happening in
vegas.
Right.
I think I Just told you about that.
Gm is doing something weird.
Yeah.
I think group things are going to be
really interesting in that too.
Like everybody experiencing that in a
group the same way you experience like a
movie in a group,
you know,
it's entirely possible that they'll
develop something like that,
right?
Where they'll have warehouses where
people meet up and everybody goes into
these virtual worlds together.
Like you go on missions and shit,
just wear something that's a,
it's tuned in to the wifi signal of the
building and you're wearing like a
lightweight helmet,
like a bicycle helmet with straps on.
So it's not substance really cumbersome,
but you know,
it has enough battery life and enough
juice to get you through a one hour game
or
they have vr experiences where you can
go with your whole family and you're all
in the game wearing these things and
you,
uh,
you're in the game together.
Damn.
Yeah.
What kind of games of any like virtual
reality games,
like they have the zombie game.
Oh,
so you're running from zombies and a
warehouse.
Yeah.
I think I hold a link from a good
mythical morning.
He was talking about how he brought the
family and he was getting chased by
zombies and I had heard that there were
thinking about doing something like
that.
Now that you think of it,
but I didn't know there was an actually
a place now.
Yeah.
And roller coaster before I feel like we
talked about in Utah.
Right,
right.
Remember looking it up right now.
Yeah.
Like,
but I think that's the future.
I think the future,
this is like you go to a football field
and it's like a virtual game is being
played,
you know,
but then you've got to stop people from
like physically assaulting each other in
the virtual world.
Yeah.
You have to have a babysitter it anyway.
Right.
Now remember this,
he'd get off an elevator.
The future of virtual reality time
magazines
avoid,
let's say if a ghostbusters experience
and ones.
Yeah.
Look at that.
This incredible.
And that's cool because you're in there
in the game with your friend,
like you could see your friends,
you're in a room with them essentially.
Yeah.
So now you're wandering around and see
what they're seeing.
We get to see what they're saying.
This is going to blow their minds.
Says the verge.
Wow.
Fuck yeah,
it's already here then.
So this is one place that has this?
I believe so,
yeah.
I don't know.
There's a place here right across the
street from the grove that's like the
imax vr thing,
but I don't think it's,
it's definitely not this.
But they might have some similar.
I definitely have way too many of these
stories.
My head,
I don't know how many of them are real.
How many of them did I make that up?
Well,
when I went to the,
did the house of comedy in the mall of
America across from it.
It's great,
great,
huge.
But they have like their,
like,
uh,
across from it they have a virtual
reality arcade where it's a one is
skydiving where you're hanging.
Well it,
you know.
And that was the whole thing,
like you could tell that's going to
become more popular,
kind of like a,
a whatever.
Those arcades are everywhere in anaheim.
Yeah,
they do.
So it says downtown disney star wars.
Oh,
is that a new?
Yeah.
Oh wow.
I did
soaring over the world.
Do you ever do that?
That's a disneyland.
It's a giant screen.
I've only been at disney once and it was
bad.
You sit down in your chair and you get
lifted up and it takes you towards this
giant screen.
And on this giant screen you,
you sore all over these different parts
of the world.
Oh cool dude.
It's fucking crazy.
The ride is amazing.
You fly over all these different spots
and uh,
you experienced all this like is if
you're soaring and you feel like a light
breeze and there's different smells that
they send your way,
like the older one was soaring over
California.
You would look at this as bears like,
what are you doing,
bitch
john,
you would soar over these orange trees.
That bear looks so fake by the way,
right?
Oh yeah.
Are they cooking?
Bear
get out of here,
bitch,
um,
but the other one was soaring over
California,
which was pretty amazing too.
And you soar with the oranges.
You'd smell him.
He'd smell the water from the beach and
you,
uh,
things like that will happen.
Like the water will splash in front of
your face.
Then all of a sudden you're being in
paris or you'll be somewhere else.
It's fucking awesome.
Yeah.
I have that ethic.
Dairy talked about this on here.
I walk the plank.
I can't remember,
I said it on an chair wrote on your
podcast or a,
it's a real piece of wood and I have
like it unbalanced would wear something
underneath it.
So it kind of rocks if you're standing
on it.
Uh,
so you go up in this elevator in virtual
reality road and I have a fan that I
turn on right when the elevator door
opens
and you feel like you're walking on the
side of the building,
like on this plank.
And it,
I have my,
I have my board kind of rocky,
so yeah,
I just want us to,
uh,
and I can't do it.
I get halfway through it.
I,
I shit myself and andy was funny and uh,
I pushed my girlfriend off the board.
She was like freaking out and I just
gave her a little nudge and she goes,
oh,
and in the game if you fall off,
you fall down.
Oh my god.
Is that my girlfriend
now?
This is crazy.
Is this a new thing?
Uh,
yeah.
I think it's for the vive.
Vive.
Yeah.
And they have a new vibe out.
I need to get a better resolution and
stuff.
And supposedly they have a wireless
adapters.
You don't have all the cables anymore.
A
coming soon.
I think the world is the most addictive
archery game ever have.
Those little monsters are trying to
attack the castle.
Have you played arrows at them?
Vertical virtual pool is cool to use it.
Yeah,
because you have like,
you know,
you have controllers and you can,
like,
it's,
it's pretty realistic for.
You could play pool.
Yeah.
But if you could only play virtual pool,
regular pool,
be so fucking amazing.
If you don't to.
Oh my god,
it's a real table.
Look at the cloth.
I can feel it.
Look,
I can watch the balls click together.
The real,
the real in front of me like,
well,
I'd rather have a control where they're
pretends with my finger.
I'm going to control what they're
pretended to stick.
Yeah,
but you could also be playing it on
moon,
on the moon.
Can't be playing on the men in your tiny
little apartment where you don't have
space for a table.
That's true too.
Yeah.
There's video games.
You can play a two on your phone,
but I've never even thought about it
critically.
Kate quigley's and she's in a virtual
reality porn.
Oh boy.
She's not naked and she's sitting there,
but she's getting molested by a naked
girl and it's weird because when you're
in the virtual rail road,
your kate quigley.
Whoa.
You are her.
Jesus.
It's so weird because I had a side gig.
Oh good.
For her,
that's a virtual.
Porn has got to be a big market.
Yeah.
It's not as good as I was hoping for.
No.
Yeah,
that was weird about it.
I just like in your head,
you think it's going to be like,
oh,
this is realistic.
I was going to make masturbating way mit
better,
but it's still clunky because all the
companies that make virtual reality
porn,
they're not making like perfect
masterpiece is they're still filming it.
Sloppy and edited.
Sloppy damage for the most part.
I mean,
unless I haven't seen all of it,
but this is just a setup for brian's new
career as a porn director of virtual
reality.
These people don't know what the fuck
they're doing.
Let me show you how it's done.
Did you do the avatar?
One,
two?
No,
I did not.
Is that a recent one?
Yeah.
Disney world avatar.
Just open every time.
Yeah,
that must be amazing.
It's the real disney for.
They're going to do a,
um,
some crazy giant star wars thing out
here.
Right.
That's going to be awesome.
Yeah,
man,
it's just weird.
It's just a matter of time till there's
going to be something like that at a
consumer level.
Like,
like the avatar game.
That seems like pretty doable.
Maybe.
Maybe I just got a little cynical view
on it,
just like maybe,
maybe not super cynical,
jamie.
I like vr chat.
That's my favorite thing in the whole
entire world right now.
Talking to people in vr.
Yeah,
it's.
It reminds me of the old days of the
internet,
like when.
I don't know what would it be messaged?
Sports first came out or something.
It's just like,
oh,
why like the wild wild west right now.
Whoa,
this crazy.
And you could be
anyone like I'm windy and you can go to
a wendy's in there in all the windies
characters together a look.
There's semen pekichu,
so people just get together in these
rooms to hang out together.
Talk to the musicians that are just sit
there and play songs for you,
but as dressed up as a.
Are you talking in your voice?
Yeah,
it's here,
but some people use voice changers and
stuff like that.
Some people just.
Hello,
my name is missy.
A lot of racist people on there.
If you leave people alone,
they just become racist.
You give them notes,
those schooling,
do you know the way and put them inside
of a video game with no repercussions
for their actions.
That's the internet.
Especially if you could be like a little
girl,
I'd say terrible and words.
You know,
a little.
A blonde girl on the screen for me while
you're a 40 year old man from the bronx.
Probably didn't check it,
but the instagram update yesterday said
something about they're blocking words.
Bullies like that as well.
I wonder what other people are fucking
assholes with that man.
Again,
assholes with the being mean to people
online.
It's a new toy.
We don't to do it yet.
It's also revealing a lot of people that
you didn't know,
like a lot of people that you never got
in contact with.
Just really shitty people mean.
I'm only mean to companies like I.
I've switched to my online bullying to
only talking about bad services service
at restaurants or delivery service.
That's
well if it's warranted.
Yeah,
that's what I say,
but people get mad at me for like when I
posted those things.
I can put some of the other day at this
chicken place.
They burned everything.
They sent me like everything.
Like the corn on the cob was black.
That chicken was black.
I had to throw it away and I was late
too.
Be the chef and the lady working of the
counter and they weren't paying
attention.
Eat chicken.
It's probably some 14 year old kid.
Frequent problem.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Probably some kid who wasn't paying
attention.
I just had a good fantasy of what was
really happening.
It was fun.
I fucked in a frigerator of restaurant.
Hey houlihan's easy fella.
Uh,
uh,
dated a girl.
Worked at uh,
newport creamery with me.
What's that like?
A,
like a cold stone ice cream place that
served hamburgers.
Who's that?
You remember me.
It's me.
This fucking phone.
I've got a phone that for whatever
reason,
turns itself on to ring all the time.
Yeah.
Like even when I don't,
it turns the cell phone to ring.
It's done it like twice.
You know what?
I think it's this case,
this leather apple case.
I think it's a piece of shit.
Like look at your volume buttons,
look at mine.
They're sunk in the middle.
Like this suddenly had this like a for a
week and it's already falling apart.
None not
join it.
Overheats your phone.
I think because of the leather,
there's no way for the air to get out.
So my shit's running slower than it
should.
You don't have to do the other day.
I put a battery pack on this.
Like a madman.
A?
Yeah.
Yeah,
put one of them thick ass battery packs
on it felt like a superhero.
I could just go all day.
Why don't you have it on now?
Because I took it off because I feel
like it was relying on it too much.
I should just charge it at night.
I'm using my phone less and less after
my trip to Hawaii because my phone broke
a dropped it the first day there and I
had to order a new one.
I mean mine to stop working.
The whole thing?
Yeah.
Duty would just randomly call people.
I would hold up,
I would hold up my contacts and it would
just start calling people and then I
would hang up and it would start calling
another person.
No,
hang up.
It was dark and I was showing people.
It's like my friend John Dudley.
I was like,
watch this watch was doing and then I'd
hang up and we'll do that again.
I was like,
what the fuck?
I just dropped it and just went haywire.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
I broke it.
And so,
uh,
when I got a new one for three days I
wasn't doing anything.
So for three days waiting for my phone
to come,
I didn't use any apps,
any,
nothing.
And I felt better.
I felt better.
But you're in Hawaii?
Yeah.
Were in van.
Nice.
But as soon as I got the phone back
again,
like,
hmm,
let me check instagram.
Anybody put any cool pictures of cars up
technology,
so frat and like that.
Then why are we still so scared of like
ai?
If we could just fucking smack it and
the breads a silly way to look at
nuclear bombs.
Jamie,
that's technology to remember that said
it was silly.
I started off by saying smoke too much
weed,
dude.
A dude,
uh,
or not enough.
Hmm.
Huh?
We should be worried.
Don't you think if elon musk thinks we
should be worried.
He's like in the business of that though
of worrying people.
No,
no,
but I mean of technology.
It's key.
Yeah.
Well also,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's not the business 100 percent.
One hundred percent.
But like that's his business.
Thirty five percent future of all
technology.
He's,
he's the one figuring out the problems.
He was the one here to save us from all
of this shit.
That's his business that he created.
All those tesla's got recalled.
I mean,
did you saw that?
Right?
Like $130,000 model ss got recalled
because they're steering column was
fucked up or something.
Is that what happened?
I don't know the exact problem,
but a lot of them.
I remember seeing something.
How crazy is it?
Ford canceled all their current.
Callan loves his.
He fucking loves it.
Yeah.
Ford decided to start making cars except
the motherfucking mustang.
An suv is I think,
well their suv,
they're awesome.
They make that lincoln town.
What is it not?
I'm good.
Why did they make it?
That's lincoln navigator,
this new navigator.
It's a fucking incredible car.
It's incredible.
It's like they.
They saw all these other cars like that
luxury suv family wagon market is a
weird market.
Like there's range rovers and there's a
bunch of mercedes suv and bmw suv,
but this is like the first other than
the cadillac escalade kinda.
But this was like another level,
like super high tech family,
luxury sled that hauls ass.
It's pretty dope dude.
I watched some of the videos on it and
how they make these things and like all
the different features that they have in
them.
Huge screens now.
Everything has giant screens.
Like a lot of these cars now,
they don't have a dashboard.
They just have a screen and you know,
you could,
you could customize it in different.
My mind is a fake screen screen screen.
Virtual gauges,
right?
Yeah.
It comes on and says,
man,
it's crazy.
It's weird.
It's weird to see.
I got a video.
We should watch this coming up from the
google io thing.
It might counter contradict what we were
just says.
No joke.
Google assistant will start making phone
calls to.
Yeah,
businesses to make appointments on your
behalf.
It's called google duplex.
The api call or even ads?
Oms and ems.
Oh,
jesus.
Haircut for a client.
I'm looking for something.
I mean,
it's not a real voice.
If
you have anything that
she would like her to be looking for.
Just the woman hair cut for now.
We of
had a.
Okay.
What's
the first thing that we thought?
Okay,
perfect.
great.
Thanks.
Have a great day.
Bye.
That's awesome.
I love that.
Totally freaked me out.
Yeah.
Okay,
so now you're back.
That's crazy.
I think we just learned something.
I think we're going to be having
conversations with those things.
It's going to be like that movie with
joaquin.
Yeah,
that's her.
That's her.
That is her
man.
It's just a matter of time.
I don't know how much time,
but it's definitely 20 years.
In 20 years you're going to have people
calling you.
You're going to have me calling you.
I'm going to call you and say some goofy
shit.
It's not even going to be me.
I'm going to call you up and go,
dude,
what are you doing right now?
Come on.
Fuck sleep.
Let's go do something.
Let's get in the car.
Let's go drive.
Let's just go drive to joshua tree right
now and do mushrooms.
Fuck it.
You don't have any kids.
And we'd be like,
okay,
I'll be by your house in 20 minutes.
You'd be out there waiting while I'm
home sleeping.
Well,
it is weird when he talked to like,
you know,
they can call up apple or something like
that and you had the automated assistant
and they had the fake typewriter.
Sounds like,
oh,
let me back.
It makes me mad.
It makes me may still do that.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I've heard that.
The.
Oh my god,
that's so crazy.
Limit check.
Right?
Why don't you just take that out and
just be fascinating here.
So let me hear some of that fake
typewriter south.
That's hilarious.
I forgot they do that.
Yeah,
apple does that.
Oh,
it's so clunky to sounds shitty.
I just wish apple had more options,
you know,
like I get that they only one to have
one phone and a few different versions
of it rather,
you know,
they have a small one.
If the big one,
the middle sized one
from Canada revenue agency.
The reason why the appliances in touch
with you by you that
back in your text.
Yeah.
This is a scammer attack scammer,
but what brian said was that when you
call apple,
they would have a fake typewriter sound
in the background,
but I did get scammed by that text
scammer.
I think he just got scammed by.
That guy was the one I was talking about
earlier.
That's a lyric,
but they didn't really yet.
Yeah,
no,
I knew right away you got knocked off.
I did tell my accountant.
He goes,
yeah,
they don't do that.
That's what I thought.
You need to contact me with your worried
about right now.
Like who's who's hearing that going?
Look,
I got a contact.
You hold on.
I'm in walmart right now.
Let me get to my car.
Hello?
I'm calling you back about the tax
thing.
Oh,
we are so lucky that you have contacted
me at this moment for dangers in the
air.
Sir.
Did you fake type?
Did you see chris delea in or with this
logan guys?
I only know about it because young
jamie,
and for me that it might've been one of
the most epic battles.
So funny man.
He uh,
he owned them so hard to the point where
I thought whatever the guy's name is is
like,
oh,
he's making fun of a kid or something
like that.
Like he calls himself like a younger
guy.
He calls him an old man.
This old man making fun of a young
whippersnappers.
Young people always like to point that
out.
That you're older.
Yeah,
they think it's hilarious because
they're so terrified of getting old.
Yeah.
Like everybody is so like there's this
thing or someone will make fun of who
you broke.
You broke your fucking 36 years old.
Like
what does it mean?
It's almost over bro.
Six hundred and 59,000 likes.
He said,
at least when my career dies,
you can film it and put it on youtube
meme that suicide for.
Why does Logan Paul?
He's responding to his.
Oh,
I'm laughing.
Cause now I know why your comedy career
took a dive.
Oh jesus.
He get owned.
And so then chris
says to him that,
yeah,
at least with my career dies,
you can film it,
put it on youtube.
That is 658,000 likes more than trump in
any,
any tweet trump's ever had.
And leah,
you need to run for president.
Uh,
it gets a strong that is now strong
that,
that responses,
that's like the strongest response I've
ever seen because this is logan in
response to that say,
but knock it a lie.
This single tweet is funny.
Then your entire netflix special.
Thanks.
How's it feel to have your name finally
attached to something funny?
Oh,
oh,
oh my god.
Amazing.
God,
I don't know what's worse,
being the shun vlogger or being the 38
year old comedian arguing with the
shunt,
vulgar on twitter.
Ask your fans to have their moms read
this out loud to them.
See what they.
God,
that's good.
Oh my god.
He's the wrong guy to fuck with he.
He'll do this all day old people
roasting me.
Greatest thing on planet earth.
How about this?
You're my son.
Tag your fucking daddy.
I'm fucking dead.
Well,
what's the thing that he deleted?
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Damn powerful.
Kristalina.
Fucking love it.
Hard in the paint
crystal.
Funny dude.
Man data.
His instagram stories or some of my
favorites.
Anything chris does is pretty fucking
funny.
So far you've called me daddy and
admitted to watching my entire comedy
special.
Are you trying to burn me or fuck me.
Okay.
That's all right.
I get it.
Just delirious.
I don't know why you would try to fight
a professional comedian on twitter.
He's a comedian.
A guy like chris who loves that kind of
shit.
He loves that kind of stuff.
Who doesn't?
That's.
Yeah,
he's like an artist,
but that kind of stuff like perfectly
like not aggressive.
You know everything about it.
It's like it was very smooth.
It was very good.
Here.
It's like the old days,
you know,
putting people on the.
That was a very good one.
You know,
people are so weird.
They really are.
I'm just wondering what's going to be
the next thing that people,
you know,
like instagram seems to be like a that's
a,
a platform.
People like they like pictures and text
behind the pictures,
but like what is going to be the next
thing?
Is it going to be some sort of augmented
thing,
some virtual thing or some goggles thing
or it's got to be something that's going
to be something in another space other
than just your phone.
I really think that there's gonna come a
time where the same amount of time that
people spend on social media,
they're going to spend some sort an
augmented state,
like you'll be able to wear these things
for work because they help you pull
things up so people just accept.
I have to have my goggles.
Like everybody wears goggles at a
certain point in time because it's just
so much cooler.
It adjusts for vision,
gives you perfect vision.
That black mirror episode about the
human,
the dvr when everyone can record,
but yes,
that's.
I mean so many other black mirror things
have sort of been coming true.
That seems like the most realistic one
that might happen.
I think.
Recording memories.
Yeah,
probably someday.
I think they're close.
I saw an article recently.
They're close to being able to either
record your dreams and play them back
for you or reinterpret them after you're
awake,
but I think it's record them as you're
sleeping and kind of find out what you
were.
Maybe rewatch it or something.
I hope not.
What if the shits in high def if like
falling
buildings in high def
demons or barking at you?
No,
I.
I had.
Do you ever out of nowhere just have a
dream.
You're like embarrassed that you even
thought that even though you had no
control of it.
A lot of them theoretically recording
dreams is possible.
Scientists are trying to cover magazine
march.
Of course it is.
They just got to figure out how to get
into the door with eventually if people
survive,
they're going to have with every
generation a greater greater
understanding of how to manipulate
things around them.
It's just what people strive for.
Strive for manipulating the environment,
manipulating electrical currents,
manipulating concrete,
moving things around,
shaping things that we just keep getting
better and better and better at it.
Of course,
we're going to keep getting better and
better at it technologically to can I
have some crazy shit,
man,
and we're going to wonder why we did it.
We're going to all be stuck.
Some strange,
weird matrix like environment we're
already are.
It seems like it easily could be
happening.
Not necessarily like right now,
but on the way to that,
like what's the logical conclusion?
I mean is does anybody believe that
people at this point are going to back
up?
That they're going to go,
hey,
you know what?
This technology is just getting too much
into our lives.
We went to a restaurant last night.
Dad was on his phone.
This kid's got a 12 inch ipad propped up
in front of them.
The other kid on the other side of the
table has a 12 inch ipad propped up in
front of him and they're just watching
three different things and no one's
talking to each other and they're there
at a sushi joint.
Wow.
And you're like,
wow,
this is what people do.
They get together,
they put a show on in front of the kid,
hey,
go.
And they just the entire time,
not even like the parents are done,
they want to talk and can I use your
phone,
your head?
Go ahead and use my phone and play a
game.
The kids playing in the game,
somebody talking to somebody?
No,
nobody's talking to anybody.
Everybody's looking at it.
An electronic device.
You go to public place and they sit down
and then not interacting with each
other.
It is super normal,
man.
If you look around,
it's super normal,
super normal,
weird.
We're going to wonder about that in a
few years.
We're going to wonder like how do they
let that in?
How do they lead this?
Like I was watching these little kids.
I was like,
okay,
I don't want to be a judge parent,
but just I'm just looking at it like a
human.
How much less time are they spending
talking to people now,
how many less awkward moments at the
dinner table we had a workout.
Just controlling your temper or
controlling your emotions are
controlling the way you interact with
people or trying to be nicer about some
of the ways you say things and learning
to get that.
The only way people learn about that
stuff is at a dinner table,
right?
Talk to each other.
That's part of like how people learn to
communicate with each other,
sitting down at dinner.
Right.
All of a sudden everyone's like watching
a screen.
How much less time are we spending
talking
like how much shittier are people going
to be if they continue doing that at
talking to real people and is that an
issue?
I think it is.
I think people don't have as strong as
compassion with each other,
like as much as much compassion and then
mike value human life.
That's why there's more school shooters
and and you know,
the realness of it.
It's kind of getting faded,
you know,
death is way more in your eyes nowadays
as a kid than it was when we were young.
We were just,
you know,
playing with frogs and playing cops and
robbers.
We didn't have internet to see death.
We didn't have.
Tv wasn't about death at the time.
You know,
a video.
Video games is all death.
I mean you have lives in video games
when,
when was the,
you have lives when you're a kid,
you know,
the cats had that.
That's a good point,
man.
I mean especially how much you could see
on the internet,
the,
the amount of horrible shit that people
see on a daily basis on the internet.
Like people will tell me,
hey,
you want to see this video?
I'm like,
no,
I've seen enough.
I know what people are capable of.
I'm good.
Some people not though.
Some people all day watching fucked up
shit,
don't,
don't start with cable though.
Do you remember how it started with
cable and when we were an older.
I wasn't old enough but
sorta,
but it really started with videotape.
Okay.
Like faces of death and shit like that.
You started seeing the face of death.
I remember the video a friend of mine
sent me was a girl walking towards the
train.
She's not paying attention and she gets
nailed by the train and it's fucking
horrific man.
She just gets torn apart.
You watch and you're like,
oh my god.
Oh my god.
It's hard to watch.
I used to always talk about this,
but what was,
it was definitely faces of death and it
was definitely ufc one,
two and three,
you know,
like the early days of ufc seeing mixed
matched like people go at it and just
the brutal kaos you know,
and there was no rules back then.
It was just like death.
You're.
There wasn't very many rules like you
couldn't eye gouge where you could punch
in the nuts.
Right.
And you never saw that before it was
boxing on tv.
It was never like,
oh my god,
these guys are fighting like dirty,
dirty fighting and pulling hair and not
punching shit.
Yeah.
I think that's probably true too.
I think our appetite for stimulation is
increasing.
That's what I think for real.
I think that's why people like so many
thrilling things.
I think we're developing a stronger and
stronger appetite for stimulation.
That's what I think it is,
dude.
And and I think the internet and you
know,
just so many different things you could
see like how,
how was it the weekend like
instantaneously pull up video of a
volcano eating a car.
I mean,
what,
how many people are supposed to see
that?
Like,
you're not supposed to see that shit all
day from all over the world.
You're not supposed to see all these
different volcano eruptions and
different shootings and cars running
over people in times square and all that
crazy shit.
If he lived in Kansas,
a lava shouldn't really be.
Yeah,
it should be on your list of shit.
You got a small amount of things to
think about in front of you.
You could live forever at each
direction.
Everything's flat.
You shouldn't be worried about lava
should you wish you should have some
fucking lava to mix things up.
That's gotta be a weird place to be,
man.
When you're watching that earth crack
open and you realize how thin the crust
is between you and the most insane shit
ever.
Rivers of hot molten rock,
right under the surface of the ground.
You're walking on like,
what?
How much is down there?
Why did we camp out here?
I get paranoid.
It's still at earthquakes.
I was in the belly room at the comedy
store the other day,
packed.
Right?
And if it was just like the big
earthquake,
then we would all be dead.
It was too many people.
There would be no escape this one place
because you know what I mean?
But I got that in my head.
I'm like,
alright,
I gotta get outta here.
So terrible thing to think of a building
and it starts collapsing or any parking
garage,
living here in la,
we go to this whole parking garages
downtown here,
like,
oh yeah,
I'm going to be a sandwich.
Something.
Yeah man,
I,
I came to la right after the first
earthquake.
Uh,
first one,
obviously the big one,
the last big one.
Um,
and then there was some small ones after
that.
There was a,
I think that one of the biggest ones was
san francisco.
I think san francisco was during the
world series.
It was a really big one.
Right.
How big was that one?
I think.
Was it going on during a game?
Yeah,
in the middle of the game world started
to end.
That'd be cool footage.
San francisco gets a lot of them.
There was a six point nine is the same
as the one on why.
Wow.
What's the coincidence of that?
Huh?
Wow.
That's some powerful shit.
And
just the.
To me
it's a.
It's a thing that we all know to be
true,
but you don't think about it until it
happens.
We all know that the earth's mantle
shifts and moves.
We know that,
that it happens.
We know that earthquakes happen.
We know the volcanoes happen,
but even so it's still
the hesitation allowing jose conseco to
score and he goes to get dave parker.
So when is the earthquake here?
Second phase.
So the oakland a's.
It's like a scene in a movie.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Wow.
That's just one of those things.
You know,
we think of it like,
yeah,
the earthquakes are real,
but until it actually happens at scary,
it was kind of scary.
You felt a good one,
right?
You felt a little bit of a tremor.
It seems like it used to be way more
when I first moved here.
Like I almost feel one like once a month
for awhile.
I haven't felt one in a long time.
It's on tape right here.
What is red bands feeling?
The earth.
Oh yeah.
This is when I was.
I felt
this is probably the biggest one.
I remember really.
Death squad studio
isn't frozen.
This happened to me before we to.
There it goes.
I started thinking about our insurance
covers this
frozen.
Is it youtube is fault on my computer.
Oh,
is that?
is it the machine?
Yeah.
Tri caster think.
Oh yeah,
that,
that freaked me out because we had the
studio at the ice house and I kept on
thinking about the ceiling.
Just cave in because that's like an old
building.
Yeah.
And I freaked the fuck out,
but that was scary.
I think they did something to make it
earthquake compliant though.
Do you know if I'm.
I hope I'm right about this.
You're right.
Do you know how you walked through the
courtyard area?
Yeah,
yeah.
They put all that stuff apparently to
reinforce it from earthquakes.
Yeah,
I mean that the walls or something it
might fix but not the ceiling fucking
fall right through it links.
It's already have that building's phone.
Like what?
Nineteen 50 something I probably said
earlier than that.
I mean I think crazy old,
right?
Like it's.
I think it's been an operation as a
nightclub since the sixties.
I think it started out as an actual ice
house,
like way earlier than that opened in
1960,
1969.
It opened the ice house.
What was it before in that building?
I'm pretty sure in that building and it
wasn't actual ice house,
which is why they decided to call it the
ice house.
You know,
sean's doesn't work there.
Yeah,
I know.
It sucks.
Twenty years.
He's an awesome guy.
Place is so sweet.
Well,
where do you go?
Uh,
I'm not sure.
I haven't talked to him about it on the
air.
Go tom.
You said besides therapist now.
Hey,
he does it better than anybody at first.
Feels weird because you know,
the air blows it in there.
Oh,
I don't think that's,
that's not fda approved.
Could you imagine if this was,
is that a rub maps still a thing when
backpage still funny.
I know this went backpage,
uh,
went down a rub.
Maps kind of freaked out for like a week
and said like,
hey,
you know,
we're not,
we're,
we're not open right now.
Nothing's working.
Uh,
you won't be charged this month.
and uh,
but then like a couple of weeks later
that it's back in,
it was always working to like,
it just had this weird notice before it.
Well,
I wonder how people feel,
you know,
that are in that business,
those backpage companies and all those,
those companies that are,
you know,
those,
uh,
some that's like the classifieds,
right?
Right.
Like,
so they have to pay to be in the
classifieds that don't work.
So they lose all that business,
all of it.
It's like a nonverbal business anymore.
Well,
roadmaps was good because it was like
yelp for a massage parlor and and so you
if you wanted to go.
I use it for the opposite reason.
Now we're like,
the other day I wanted a real massage
and I checked to make sure that that
wasn't a rub and tug place.
Right.
Because they're all rubbing to have
places here in los angeles.
Like it's hard to find one that's not
now and sometimes you just don't want
that.
You want a real massage.
I guess what I said doesn't make sense
though because it's illegal activity.
So as long as it's illegal activity,
of course they have to take it down.
No,
I don't think.
Not really.
What do they say?
Freedom of speech and shit.
Like,
like you're allowed to talk about
cocaine,
you're not going to get your website
taken down.
And that's crazy.
Like
not even what I mean.
I mean I don't,
I don't think that.
I feel like if you're a person who is
making this decision and like 2018 you
saying,
you know what,
we've got to crack down on prostitution.
We got to figure out a way to.
We got to figure out a way to put a stop
to this.
Like,
what are you wasting your time doing
that for a don't we have other really
big issues that we have a hard time
finding enough people to tackle.
The biggest problem is sex trafficking.
That's the real reason.
Like there's too much traffic.
Yeah,
that.
That's a big one.
I'm
just.
When everything's unregulated,
right?
Anything that's unregulated,
you're always going to find someone who
fills that gap was a criminal.
Anything that's illegal that people
want,
whether it's drugs,
anything.
It's really hard to tell people what
they can and can't do.
It's really hard.
It doesn't seem to make any sense.
You shouldn't be able to.
As long as no one's getting hurt,
you know?
Like what if someone decides,
hey man,
we at this furry thing
and you guys are just too weird.
You can't do this anymore.
You can't just dress up like mascots and
have sex with each other and eat a dog.
Food bowls can't do that anymore.
That's neat.
These people ever.
They're having a party as furries.
What if someone came,
comes along and says,
you can't do that anymore.
It's too weird.
Have reacted fine.
I mean,
I just think it's weird where people
just can decide what other people can
and can't do.
Especially when it comes to something as
ridiculous as sex
touching is that thing that makes no
sense.
Like hand jobs should not be illegal.
No.
Like you're allowed to touch my arm but
you can't touch my dick.
It's going to be real weird.
When robots are fuckable like really
weird when they're really fuckable like
they're hot.
You know the hot.
It feels good.
What if someone raped that robot?
Is it going to have rights?
Jesus christ going to kill you,
bro.
They don't need to sleep.
That chick's gonna wait until your sleep
and then she's going to fucking elbow
your eye sockets right through.
Like I got arrested for like fucking a
car recently or something like that.
Yeah,
I didn't hear about that.
I think it's a matter of time before
they develop an ai in a physical body
that's so closely resembles a human body
that you could turn the lights down,
light a candle,
those new ones,
like the hottest girl in the world.
You've seen the new ones,
right?
The new sexual sex robots,
the ones I think they're making,
they make them in san diego.
I think it's the same guy that made the
real dog,
but that he has that new ai and the new
bodies.
It's it.
You can order it now.
I think a preorder it now it's a,
they had a video of it and then the ai
is pretty legit and it's not bad.
Uh,
it talks to you.
It remembers you.
You can pick the face,
you can design what you want it to look
like.
A dude.
It's a matter of time.
I know as a matter of time,
I know a comedian,
you know fleshlight you remember
flashlight.
They,
I guess they make these motorized
flashlights now.
Like we kinda just strokes you.
Why you fucking so my friend a comedian,
we know.
I won't say who it is,
but he injured his dick hole from,
went too hard and went too hard and he
had to go to the doctor and tell
a terrible story.
Jesus christ.
Dude,
that's terrible story.
I kind of fleshlight dealer day.
I haven't used one in a while.
Do you still use yours?
All right.
I think this podcast is basically over.
Brian just hit the wall.
It's a.
It's been a while.
We were like three hours into it.
I don't use it anymore.
I always felt so much more shame using
it that I did use my hand,
but it does feel better.
Way better.
It does.
That's legit.
This traveling has are nice.
We shoot through it so you don't even
have to like clean it up anymore.
You just shoot through it.
He didn't make this whole mabel and what
does this
guy made?
A homemade dick soccer.
Jesus christ.
This looks terrible.
He's got metal and ivc pipe.
The pipe is cut at 45 degrees.
Flashlight,
pvc pipe the fuck out of here.
He's got a.
It's got like a little kid's toy train.
It's going to shoot you right onto his
dick.
Let's go look at it.
Nylon nuts,
bolts,
washers,
aluminum,
plywood,
12 volt power supply.
One hundred and 50,000.
Oh my god.
Such a bad idea.
He changed.
That is hilarious.
So it's gonna slowly bullshit.
Oh,
he can control the pace that it blows
them.
Proof of concept.
Yeah.
Whatever,
bro.
Tighten the flesh.
One motorized flashlight to see if what
I did.
That's how I got this one.
Well,
listen to the first.
I think.
I think we can wrap this up safely.
I miss this.
These are strange days.
I think we learned a lot today.
I did not know that you could make a
fucking phone call with an artificial
intelligence thing that could say um,
and would make appointments for you and
shit.
And we all learned that.
That scared the shit out of me.
I didn't know about these choo choo
train fake vagina attractions that these
kids are hacking is wacky kids.
I learned that I'm not.
I am very confused when it comes to the
future.
Very.
This stuff is.
I think this is all happening in front
of us and I think it's insanely crazy,
insanely transformative and it's
happening and we don't have a fucking
clue as to where it's going and there's
nothing we can do about it.
It's we're all like,
well,
it is what it is.
I think it's nuts.
I think we are.
We're 20 years from the fucking matrix
and we're seeing it happen.
We're seeing it happen right now in
front of us.
We're seeing a little baby steps like,
nah,
we're so far off.
Yeah.
I went to that whole thing the other
day.
It was nothing went to the conference.
Nah,
not that impressed me.
Which would you rather find out that
we're about to be in it or that we've
been in it the whole time?
Which would make you more comfortable?
That's a very good question.
Damn,
that's a good question.
What do you think?
I think we're already in it so
well.
Gun to the head,
which you do.
Why would she say?
I think the reality itself is obviously
some sort of weird thing because you're
looking at it,
you looking at it through your eyes,
your eyes are determining the positions
that things are in and what they look
like and where things are and there's
all these things that are going on
around you all the time that you have no
control of and they're everywhere all
over the planet.
People living lives and you interface
with those lives.
Occasionally you just accustomed to the
manner in which you do it,
so it seems normal,
but every night you close your eyes and
you go unconscious and who knows what
the fuck happens to your brain and then
you wake up in the morning and you have
to pee and you're struggling to try to
figure out what happened yesterday and
then while this is happening,
your ex girlfriend's fucking your best
friend from high school and they got
together and can't believe jamie left.
I mean he said he was going to stay
forever and then next thing you know
like this is all these lives intersect
with each other all over the world.
It is kind of a hologram.
It's kind of a crazy react.
If the real life wasn't real,
it would be super interesting.
You'd be like,
look at the way life works.
Look at the way they breathe in and
breathe out carbon dioxide and the trees
breathe into carbon dioxide and breathe
out air,
but they keep chopping down the trees.
They keep chopping down the trees.
They don't care.
They're like,
who cares?
I want paper to wipe my ass with a tree.
Just wipe their ass with trees.
Literally they grind millions of trees
down every year and turned into pulp so
they can make paper to wipe their ass.
They literally wiped her ass with
nature.
Why don't they just use soap and water?
No,
no.
I want a treat.
I want some pulverized treated.
Wipe my ass with tissue paper,
tissue paper.
It's fucking trees.
It's tissue paper really made out of
trees.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
Synthetic tissue paper that's made out
of like dolphin tears.
Something worse.
What are they,
what it's like synthetic toilet papers
that real.
I mean,
look,
they have tofu chicken,
right?
You don't think they have like some sort
of an organic plastic out of it?
I think.
Did they make toilet paper and would it
be too rough?
They'd be the best thing ever.
Free free bathroom tissue.
Hemp.
Someone's doing it.
So I'm putting it together.
Is it a startup for you?
Dude?
I was.
I was reading all the people that
invested hundreds of millions of dollars
into that scam.
A blood test company.
That blood test company story is crazy.
Toronto's there was this woman and they
were calling her like the next steve
jobs,
but the female steve jobs even dressed
like I'm short black turtlenecks.
Yeah,
and she,
she had become this self made person I
think from college started this company
and then by the time she was like 40,
whatever she was when they busted her,
she was worth $34,000,000,000 because
there's blood testing thing that she had
developed and then as time went on they
realized that it didn't really work and
then all these people had invested like
betsy devos,
I think it was.
And warren buffet had warren buffet
invested over $100,000,000 or 25.
Yeah.
In this company that was bullshit.
So these,
they put these people's health at risk
because they gave them these tests and
the test didn't work and they're showing
that they kind of knew the test didn't
work with this is how this woman dressed
all the time.
It's um,
it's really interesting,
man.
It's so really interesting story because
when you see the amount of money that
people invested into it and then they're
just shit out of luck.
She went from being worth.
I think she was worth something crazy.
Like the richest woman ever are the
richest self made woman ever.
Something along those lines is,
I think she was worth like $34 million
dollars at one point.
Has a twitter.
Yeah.
And then she's recently been charged
with massive fraud.
I don't know.
I mean I don't know shit about that
business.
So I don't know if the blood tests did
or didn't work or if she's got a store
that needs to be told.
And I don't know,
it was just,
it.
Just read what you read and what you
read is that they,
they've fibbed about results and they
did some shit they shouldn't have done
and all these people got tests and they
thought they were,
you know,
if you get a blood test,
you think you're getting the accurate
results from a reputable company.
And it wasn't that,
it was a micro click,
like they would take like a micro prick
of blood and they would take that blood
and they would measure it and that's how
they would find whether you had diseases
or not.
Yeah,
I use that one.
All self made woman worth four and a
half billion.
Okay.
So why don't I save 34?
So that's not even real.
It has that much like three guys,
a couple other people.
Okay.
So she's worth 4 billion.
That's still nothing to sneeze at.
It's like a two bedroom apartment
remembered for I see a four.
Is it your father?
Who is it?
Who is hitting the past?
Um,
so this,
this,
this thing,
the store,
when it came out that all these people
that invested hundreds of millions of
dollars into it,
it made me think like,
can you imagine how long it takes to
make 100 million dollars to have 100
million dollars to invest in something
that's bullshit.
You imagine like what it must feel to
find out that that shit didn't work.
Like what?
Like yeah,
you invested in a scam.
It's all bullshit.
What?
Yeah,
she's being charged with massive fraud.
No,
no.
Yeah,
you're $100.
Million dollars has gone.
What?
What the fuck did you just say your
hundred million dollars is gone.
They just got arrested.
She got charged with massive fraud.
What?
I said she's in prison is happening on
the crypto market with the ico initial
coin offerings.
What's called.
People will make some sort of pitch and
pitch people that there are new startup
is worth it and instead of taking
investor money,
they take cryptocurrency if you will.
And then after they gain a bunch,
they just disappear.
It happens almost every week.
Now
exit scammers run off with 660 million
in ico earnings.
See,
this is like what you were saying about
the nigerian people getting online and
them not knowing certain scams and then
we get.
It's like scammers find a way in every
system.
[inaudible].
There's not tons of scams out there.
They're just getting repurposed,
you know,
that just another trick,
they just put a little twist on it
changes name and it's a new scam,
but it's,
it's all the same scams.
Actually.
You might want to know my pistol scam
postal.
Yeah.
I've actually never done this.
But uh,
it's like where you get arrested for
what you're about to say.
Well,
I don't know.
I've been approached on a pit bull
strong.
Those motherfuckers come down on you.
I've never done it,
but this is something that uh,
I think somebody told me they used to do
in college.
I don't know.
I don't even know if it really works,
but like I said,
like I wanted to send you a letter a.
I would put you as the uh,
yeah,
just switching return address and the
address.
Throw it in one of those blue mailboxes.
Hey,
they'll go,
hey.
No stamp returned to sender.
Now I sent you that letter.
Okay.
They probably know that one already.
Yeah,
they probably.
Do you do that with like a letter
though?
Probably.
Yeah.
They're probably like,
what?
How do you get all the way over here?
She's dropped off in California.
It's supposed to be in Ohio.
Fuck out here.
They know better.
They know better today.
Yeah.
They're smarter than you,
bro.
There's like a hippie skin,
so let's be scared together.
Let's wrap this up.
We should be scared of technology.
Agreed.
That's great.
This is getting out of hand.
Agreed.
It's on sway.
What am I?
I definitely know I'm under the
influence of marijuana,
but I'm going fun.
Tell us a really fun technology.
It's very fun.
It's very fun to do this show.
Oh yeah.
I'm not anti technology.
I'm not even anti war.
This is going.
I'm.
I'm just.
I'm just like,
oh my god.
There's a waterfall coming up guys.
We're on a raft.
There's a waterfall coming up.
You told me it's okay.
You can go over the waterfall.
Okay,
okay.
Friends if need protection.
I don't know if we can.
I don't know if we're going over this
waterfall.
If we're going to make it will be fine.
Robot fucked off.
They're coming already.
Planning to take over your life.
Don't,
don't,
don't.
All right.
Brian,
uh,
what do you got coming up?
Shows a tonight.
Improv with public francisco and I said
what's up and this weekend with me and
tony are taking tony to vegas so we'll
be in vegas.
And then the follow up,
uh,
we're playing this place called the dive
bar,
which is I guess seats 200 people.
It's like an old bar that's been there
forever,
but uh,
there's still take us to that san
francisco is sought out and then we're
going to be in detroit with danny brown
is going to be a on killed.
Tony with us in Texas and we're all over
the place.
Death squad.tv.
Click on tour dates.
Excellent.
And if you look at for a paddle,
you don't have your powerful shirt on
young jamie.com.
You left a few left on one younger than
me.com.
All right,
that's it fuckers.
We'll be back tomorrow.
Thank you.
Bye.